THE ASSEMBLY IS NOW IN SESSION.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL REPARE
THE CHAMBER. AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL. ACOSTA
AGUIAR-CURRY.
ALLEN
ARAMBULA.
BAKER. BERMAN.
BIGELOW. BLOOM.
BONTA. BROUGH.
BURKE
CABALLERO CALDERON CARRILLO
CERVANTES CHAU CHAVEZ.
CHEN.
DAVID CHIU CHOI KANSEN CHU
COOLEY.
COOPER. CUNNINGHAM DALLY. DAILY.
EGGMAN FLORA.
FONG.
FRAZIER. FRIEDMAN GALLAGHER.
ISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ FLETCHER
GRAY.
GRAYSON
HARPER.
HOLDEN.
IRWIN JONES SAWYER. KALRA
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KILEY LACKEY LEVINE LOW MOAN.
LOW. MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES MCCARTY. MEDINA MELENDEZ
MULLIN MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN
OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL PATTERSON
QUIRK.
QUIRK SILVA REYES RODRIGUEZ
RUBIO.
SALAS SANTIAGO STEINORTH STONE.
THURMOND.
TING VOEPEL WALDRON WEBER WOOD
MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS PLEASE REPORT TO THE
FLOOR.
LOTS OF BUSINESS BEFORE THE
ASSEMBLY TODAY.
WE LIKE TO GET MOVING PLEASE
REPORT TO THE FLOOR MEMBERS
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE ASK THAT OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS.
IN THE REAR CHAMBER AND IN THE
GALLERY.
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY MEMBER ADRIN
NAZARIAN MISTERS AREA.
FATHER WE THANK YOU FOR ANOTHER
DAY TO WORK FOR. AND WITH OUR
FELLOW MEN WOMEN AND MEN.
WE PRAY THAT YOU. MAY BE WITH US
TODAY TO DEFEND US.
WITH US THAT YOU MAY SUSTAIN US.
BEFORE US THAT YOU MAY LEAD US.
BEHIND US THAT YOU MAY PROTECT
US.
ABOVE US THAT YOU MAY BLESS US
AND EVERYTHING THAT WE DO.
A MAN.
THANK YOU WHICH IS A WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING.
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN
US FOR OUR FLAG SALUTE PLEASE
JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOI. AS HE
LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE.
CHOI.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN PLEASE JOIN
ME IN THE PLEDGE OF I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
THE UNITED STATES OF.
SHE.
IT IS.
THANK YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED.
REALLY OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO WEDNESDAY MAY SECOND
TWENTY EIGHTEEN IF THE ASSEMBLY
MET AT SEVEN A. M. ON ALTERNATE
THURMOND ASSEMBLY MEMBER FIFTEEN
DISTRICT PROVIDING CHEAP QUICK
<c.green> DOTS AND WILSON AT THE</c>
DESK. READING CLICK KATHLEEN I'M
LUIS READING THE FOLLOWING.
REPLACEMENT MORE DIGITAL
CALDERON MOVES.
AND MISTER DALLI SECONDS OF THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE INTRODUCTION REFERENCE
TO BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE. THERE
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS.
THE ABSENCES FOR THE DAY THERE
ARE NO ABSENCES TODAY
HER PURSE
NATURAL MOTIONS.
MISTER CALDERON.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
PROCEDURAL MOTIONS THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE ONE EIGHTEEN NAY
TO ALLOW SOMEONE MEMBERS BONTA
ACOSTA FRIEDMAN EDUARDO GARCIA
AND KILEY TO HAVE GUESTS AND
PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE FLOOR TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER AND JUST TO BE CLEAR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA AS GUEST
WILL BE IN THE AREA OF THE
MEMBERS DESK IN AT THE ROSTRUM
FOR THE ASIAN AND PACIFIC
ISLANDER HERITAGE. MONTH
CEREMONY ASSEMBLY MEMBERS COSTA
AND GARCIA'S GUEST WILL BE
SEATED AT THEIR DESKS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
I ALSO REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT
TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY
FIVE POINT FIVE AND ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER O'DONNELL AND
MAYES AS WELL AS DOLLY TO SPEAK
ON AN ADJOURNMENT AND MEMORY
TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION AGAINST SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER.
AND PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE
NINETY SIX A REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO RE REFER TO THE
FOLLOWING BILL TO COMMITTEE. SB
SIXTY FOUR WHITE HOUSE YOU FROM
UTILITIES AND ENERGY COMMITTEE
TO THE RULES COMMITTEE.
THE CLERK WILL NOTE
.
MEMBERS WE HAVE GUESTS WITH US
IN THE ASSEMBLY TODAY.
I'M GOING TO RECOGNIZE MR KILEY
FROM MY DESK IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER. MEMBERS PLEASE KEY
RETENTION MISTER KILEY.
I THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
HAVE TWO VERY SPECIAL GUESTS ON
ALONG WITH THEIR MOTHERS AYE
WITH ME HERE TODAY. BUSTER
CARLSON AND JACOB HOW YOU WHO
ARE.
BOTH SENIORS AT WHITNEY HIGH
SCHOOL.
LAST APRIL BUSTER AND WHITNEY
WERE ON YOU TO.
AND THEY NOTICED ANA COMMENTS
THREAD.
A SHOOTING THREATS. DIRECTED AT
A SCHOOL IN FLORIDA.
THE COMIC CONCLUDED TERRA BELLA
HIGH SCHOOL IS MY TARGET I'M
LEGIT NOT JOKING AROUND.
NOW. BUSTER AND JACOB COULD HAVE
JUST GONE ON WITH THEIR LIVES
AND FIGURED SOMEONE ELSE.
WOULD DEAL WITH IT.
BUT THEY INSTEAD DECIDED TO TAKE
ACTION.
THEY KNEW THEY HAD A DUTY TO
REPORT THIS
AND THEY FILED A REPORT ON THE
FBI'S TIP LINE AND CALLED LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
LEADING TO AN INVESTIGATION.
THE NEXT DAY.
LAW ENFORCEMENT DISCOVERED.
THAT. THIS STUDENT WHO HAD
POSTED THIS COMMENT HAD WEAPONS
IN HIS HOUSE.
AND JACOB INVESTORS CALL TO THE
POLICE LED TO THE ARREST OF THE
SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD FLORIDA
STUDENT WITH THE SCREEN NAME
SHARPSHOOTER.
THEY SAW SOMETHING OF A SAID
SOMETHING AND LIVES MAY HAVE
BEEN SAVED. AS A RESULT.
BUSTER AND JAKE GOT.
DEMONSTRATED HEROIC LEVELS OF
VIGILANCE AND CIVIC
RESPONSIBILITY. AND I ASK YOU TO
JOIN ME IN OFFERING THEM OUR
UTMOST COMMENDATION AND
GRATITUDE
MEMBERS WE HAVE ADDITIONAL GAS
WITH US IN THE CHAMBER TODAY.
MEMBERS.
GOING TO RECOGNIZE MR. ACOSTA.
WHO HAS SPECIAL GUEST WITH US
TODAY MR ACOSTA
WELL THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER IT
IS MY DISTINCT PLEASURE AND
HONOR TO INTRODUCE TO YOU?
MY DAUGHTER ALEXANDRA RENEE.
SHE IS JOINING US UP FOR THE
FIRST TIME ON THE FLOOR SHE'S
BEEN A COLLEGE STUDENT TO A PILE
UNIVERSITY.
AND IS SHE GRADUATED THREE AND
HALF YEAR SO WERE AWFULLY PROUD
THAT HE'S DONE WITH THAT. AND IN
THE ALSO IN THE GALLERY WOULD
LIKE TO INTRODUCE MY SON A DOOR
AND YOU COULD STAND UP DORAN YOU
IN MINE.
AND MY DAUGHTER'S ROOMMATE
LONNIE FOR RHONDA FROM THE BAY
AREA AND SHE ALSO JUST GRADUATED
FROM BIOLA UNIVERSITY.
AND OUT LET'S.
HELP ME WELCOME MY DAUGHTER MY
SON AND.
LANI
TO THE CHAMBER THANK YOU VERY
MUCH
MEMBERS WE ARE AT SECOND
READING.
SECOND READING THE CLERK WILL
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN
NINETY SIX TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY THIRTY TWENTY EIGHT
SEVENTY THREE TWENTY SIX AND
TWENTY THREE FIFTY THREE THIRTY
TWO SEVENTEEN SEVENTEEN NINETY
TWO TWENTY TWO SIXTY THREE
NINETEEN HUNDRED WITH AMENDMENTS
POINT BETWEEN AYE WITH
AMENDMENTS. EIGHTEEN SIXTY EIGHT
TWENTY TWELVE SEVENTEEN NINETY
FOUR TWENTY EIGHT NINETY EIGHT
THIRTY TO GET SUPPORT TWENTY ONE
SIXTY FOUR TWENTY ONE SEVENTY
NINE POINT THREE SEVENTY TWO
TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY FIVE TWENTY
FIVE FIFTY EIGHT THIRTY ONE
NINETY FOUR. THIRTY SIXTY NINE
WITH AMENDMENTS THIRTY TO SIXTY
TWO THIRTY TO SIXTY THREE THIRTY
TO SIXTY FOUR TWENTY NINE FORTY
FIVE AT THE MOMENT THIRTY ONE
SIXTY TWO WITH AMENDMENTS.
TWENTY SEVENTY ONE WITH
AMENDMENTS WE NINE THIRTY TO AT
THE MOMENT. SENATE BILL FOURTEEN
NINETY SIX FOURTEEN NINETY SEVEN
AND FOURTEEN NINETY NINE.
ALL BILLS WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR PROCEDURAL MOTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER PLEASE
REMOVE THE FOLLOWING BILLS FROM
THE CONSENT CALENDAR AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHORS ITEM ONE
FORTY FOUR AB TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY FIVE RODRIGUEZ AND I.
STEEN AB THIRTY TWO FOR
YOU FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER
.
COLLEAGUES WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
THE SPECIAL CEREMONY IN HONOR OF
ASIAN AND PACIFIC ISLANDER
AMERICAN HERITAGE MONTH.
WITHOUT OBJECTION IT WILL MOVE
TO FILE ITEM ONE ZERO FOUR ACR
TO THIRTY ONE DAVID CHIU FOR THE
PURPOSE. OF THIRD READING MR
CHIU ARE YOU READY TO PROCEED ON
THIS ITEM.
OKAY THE CLERK WILL READ ACR TO
THIRTY ONE.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TO THIRTY ONE BY SOMETHING
MEMBER DAVID CHIU AND OTHERS
RELATIVE ASIAN OPPOSITE.
UNDER AMERICAN HERITAGE.
HER.
COLLEAGUES SAY APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF ACR TO THIRTY
ONE TO DESIGNATE MAY OF THIS
YEAR. AS ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
HERITAGE MONTH.
MAY WAS CHOSEN TO COMMEMORATE.
THE IMMIGRATION OF THE FIRST
JAPANESE IMMIGRANT TO THE UNITED
STATES ON MAY SEVENTH EIGHTEEN
FORTY THREE. AS WELL AS THE
COMPLETION OF THE
TRANSCONTINENTAL RAILROAD BY
CHINESE AMERICANS ON MAY TENTH
EIGHTEEN SIXTY NINE.
OUR STATE HAS A LARGEST API
POPULATIONIN THE COUNTRY WERE
NEARLY SIX POINT FIVE MILLION
ASIAN AMERICANS CALL CALIFORNIA
HOME.
AS THE FASTEST GROWING MINORITY
IN AMERICA. THIS MONTH NOT ONLY
CELEBRATES THE ACCOMPLISHMENTS
OF OUR DIVERSE ASIAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITIES. BUT REFLECTS ON THE
CHALLENGES THAT HAVE BEEN
OVERCOME AND STILL REMAIN.
TODAY WE CELEBRATE THE SUCCESSES
OF API'S IN ACADEMICS THE ARTS
BUSINESS TECHNOLOGY EDUCATION
SCIENCE GOVERNMENT. LAW SPORTS
AND SO MANY OTHER AREAS.
BUT WHILE SOME A STORM
MISTAKENLY BELIEVING THE MYTH OF
THE SO CALLED ASIAN MODEL
MINORITY. IT WAS NOT LONG AGO.
THAT THIS LEGISLATURE ON THIS
FLOOR PASS LAWS THAT PREVENTED
CHINESE AMERICANS FROM OWNING
PROPERTY.
WORKING IN MANY INDUSTRIES
MARRYING OR ATTENDING SCHOOLS
WITH NON CHINESE AMERICANS
LAWS THAT SET THE STAGE FOR THE
CHINESE EXCLUSION ACT.
JAPANESE AMERICANS HAD THEIR
PROPERTY SEIZED AND WERE
FORCIBLY REMOVED FROM THEIR
HOMES INTO INTERNMENT CAMP.
BASED ON XENOPHOBIC FEARS.
FILIPINO AMERICANS HAD THEIR
LABOR RIGHTS VIOLATED WHILE
WORKING IN OUR AGRICULTURE
FIELDS.
AND POST NINE ELEVEN. WE'VE SEEN
SOUTH ASIANS VICTIMIZED BY HATE
CRIMES AND PARITY ON THE
SIMPSON'S.
WHILE OUR COMMUNITIES HAVE COME
A LONG WAY. WE ARE IN AN ERA OF
ANTI IMMIGRANT SENTIMENT AND
RHETORIC.
WITH A FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THAT
IS LOOK TO RESTRICT THE RIGHTS
OF THOSE WHO WANT TO CONTRIBUTE
TO OUR COUNTRY.
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE MOVE
BEYOND THIS IN A PHOBIA AND
BIGOTRY. TO CONTINUE TO LIVE UP
TO OUR IDEALS OF JUSTICE AND
EQUALITY FOR ALL.
AS THE SON OF ASIAN IMMIGRANTS
AND AS A FIRST ASIAN AMERICAN TO
REPRESENT THE OLDEST CHINATOWN
IN OUR COUNTRY. AS WELL AS SAN
FRANCISCO'S JAPANTOWN LITTLE
SAIGON IN FILIPINO HERITAGE
DISTRICT. I KNOW WE ARE ALL MADE
STRONGER WHEN WE CELEBRATE OUR
HERITAGE AND SUPPORT THE
DIVERSITY OF ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITIES AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK ALL MEMBERS TO
SUPPORT. THIS RESOLUTION AND
COMMEMORATE THIS MONTH AS A P.
I. HERITAGE MONTH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHIU DOCTOR
CHOI YOU ARE RECOGNIZED AT YOUR
DESK.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND THE MEMBERS.
TO THEY ARE AS A KOREAN
IMMIGRANT AND A FIRST GENERATION
AMERICAN MYSELF. I RISE SO IN
NOT PROUD TO SUPPORT ALL FOR ACR
TO THIRTY ONE.
ASIAN AND PACIFIC ISLANDER
AMERICANS SAW ARE RESILIENT THAT
GROUP OF PEOPLE. AREN'T MANY OF
US SAYS ESCAPING REPRESSIVE
GOVERNMENTS ARE AND THE LESS
THAN IDEAL CIRCUMSTANCES.
IN THE HOPE SOLVE A BETTER LIFE
FOR.
IN THE LAND OF OPPORTUNITY THAT
IS SOUTH AMERICA.
WE ARE NOT ONLY OUR COUNTRY BUT
TO THE RICH CULTURAL UP FABRIC
OVER AMERICA BUT THE WAY YOU
ALSO. CONTRIBUTE TO A SOCIETY.
YOU KNOW MULTITUDE OF OTHER WAYS.
I WILL CONTRIBUTIONS ARE COVERED
THE ENTIRE SPECTRUM OF OUR
INDUSTRIES SAW. FROM BUSINESS.
TOOL POLITICS.
THE MUSIC TO ARCHITECTURE TO
OUGHT TO ENGINEERING THE LAW TO
EDUCATION.
YOU NAME IT. AND THAT WE HAVE
ALL MADE OUR MOCK.
IN FACT.
ACCORDING TO THE U. S. CENSUS
DATA. THERE ARE APPROXIMATELY
ONE POINT FIVE ONE POINT NINE.
MILLION.
THEY SHOULD NOT OWN THE
BUSINESSES ARE OPERATING IN THE
UNITED STATES.
WHICH BRINGS SAY NOT ABOUT COST
SIX HUNDRED TEN MINUTES BILLION.
DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
THIS SATURDAY.
THAT DIAZ OFF COURSE STILL.
PLUS ARE IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
ARE ASIAN AMERICANS AND PACIFIC
ISLANDERS SO WOULD BE YA
CELEBRATING THE TWO TRADITIONAL.
OF MONTH ABOVE ME AS SAW A.
ASIA NOT PACIFIC ISLANDER
AMERICAN MONTH.
ON A PERSONAL NOTE THIS
RESOLUTION OR SOUL FORCE ON THE
UNIT PIE.
IN THE HISTORY OF OUR OF THE
KOREAN PEOPLE.
AS WE SEE THE UNPRECEDENTED UP
BEGINNING STAGES SOLVE OUR PEACE
TALKS
BETWEEN NORTH KOREA.
SOUTH KOREA AND THE UNITED
STATES SOME OF AMERICA.
WHICH REPRESENT THE EIGHTIES.
SOURCE ALL OF OUR GREAT THE
WHOLE.
FOR PEACE TO AND OUR SECURITY
THROUGHOUT THE REGION.
AT THIS TIME IN HISTORY.
ASIAN AND PACIFIC ISLANDER
AMERICANS ARE HAVE A MATE DEL.
THINGS A IN WHICH IS TO BE YA
HOPE FOR AND THE PROBLEM.
FOR THESE REASONS SO I
RESPECTFULLY. URGE ON AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DOCTOR CHOI MISTER
LEVINE. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED AT
YOUR DESK
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE JEWISH
CAUCUS I RISE IN SUPPORT OF ACR
TO THIRTY ONE CALIFORNIA WOULD
NOT BE THE STATE IT IS TODAY.
WITHOUT THE CONTRIBUTIONS AND
ACHIEVEMENTS OF ASIAN AND
PACIFIC ISLANDER COMMUNITY IT IS
IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE THE API
COMMUNITIES ROUTES THAT ARE
DEEPLY EMBEDDED IN OUR STATE'S
HISTORY. AND TRADITION AS WE
REMEMBER THE UNDENIABLE
HARDSHIPS THEY FACED IN NINETEEN
TWENTY FOUR ASIAN IMMIGRANTS
WERE BANNED FROM ENTERING THE
UNITED STATES FOLLOWING THE
PASSAGE OF THE NATIONAL ORIGINS
ACT. THIS LAW DISCRIMINATED
AGAINST IMMIGRANTS BY
ESTABLISHING A NATIONAL QUOTA.
THIS POLICY STATE IN EFFECT
UNTIL THE NINETEEN SIXTIES
DESPITE THESE UNFAIR AND
PREJUDICE POLICIES THE API
COMMUNITY HAS PERSEVERED WITH
STRENGTH AND BRAVERY. API
IMMIGRANTS HELPED BUILD OUR
COUNTRY AND THEIR IMPACT ON OUR
STATE'S PROSPERITY REMINDS US
THAT WE MUST LEARN FROM THE PAST
CALIFORNIA'S STRENGTH AND
SUCCESS IS DEPENDENT. OF ALL
PEOPLE OF ALL BACKGROUNDS
INCLUDING THE API COMMUNITY LET
US CELEBRATE CALIFORNIA'S UNIQUE
DIVERSITY ASIAN AND PACIFIC
ISLANDER AMERICANS ARE A
TREMENDOUS. AND RESPECTED PART
OF THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER LEVINE MISS
QUIRK SILVA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
AT YOUR DESK.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE ON BEHALF OF THE
LATINO CAUCUS AND THE
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS AND
PROUD SUPPORTIVE ACR. TO THIRTY
ONE TO RECOGNIZE THE MONTH OF
MAY AS ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER.
HERITAGE MONTH.
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO OVER SIX
POINT THREE MILLION ASIAN AND
PACIFIC ISLANDER AMERICANS MORE
THAN ANY OTHER STATE API
HERITAGE MONTH SPEAKS TO THE
PROUD IN RICH HISTORY AND
CULTURE OF PEOPLE. IN SEARCH OF
THE AMERICAN DREAM RIGHT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE SAME DREAM THAT SO MANY
OTHER IMMIGRANT SHARE ACROSS OUR
COUNTRY.
WITH OVER HALF A MILLION ASIAN
AMERICANS ORANGE COUNTY IS HOME
TO THE NATION'S THIRD LARGEST
AMERICAN POPULATION.
ORANGE COUNTY HAS MANY
BUSINESSES RESTAURANTS AND
SERVICES THAT ARE OWNED AND
OPERATED BY HARD WORKING ASIAN
AMERICANS.
THE API COMMUNITY PLAYS AN
IMPORTANT PART IN OUR SEATS
CULTURE AND ECONOMY. JUST
RECENTLY IN FULLERTON A YOUNG
TEAM OF THE JUNIOR HIGH STUDENTS
AT PARKS JUNIOR HIGH ONE A STATE.
WIDE CONTEST.
THAT FOCUSED ON CYBERSECURITY
ALSO A FEW MONTHS AGO ON THE
FLOOR HERE WE REMEMBERED MARCH
FONG YOU A PIONEER. PIONEER OF
WOMEN IN CALIFORNIA POLITICS WHO
LIVED IN FULLERTON.
WE ALSO CELEBRATED WOMEN
ATHLETES OF ORANGE COUNTY LIKE
OUR OLYMPIAN CHAMPION
SNOWBOARDER CHLOE KIM.
AND THIS WEEK WE WILL ALSO
CELEBRATE KOREAN RIVIERA OF
ORANGE COUNTY A WOMAN CYCLE THIS
RACE SCENE IN THE TOUR OF
CALIFORNIA. MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN
ME IN CELEBRATING API HERITAGE
MONTH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISSED QUIRK SILVA
MISS BURKE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED AT
YOUR DESK THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
BLACK CAUCUS IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF ACR TO THIRTY ONE.
RECOGNIZING MAY TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN AS ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER AMERICAN HERITAGE MONTH.
THE AB IP I COMMUNITY MUCH LIKE
AFRICAN AMERICAN AND LATINO
COMMUNITIES HAVE FACE
SIGNIFICANT HARDSHIPS PREJUDICE
AND DISCRIMINATION IN OUR
COUNTRY WHICH LED TO SOME OF THE
WORST LAWS IN AMERICAN HISTORY.
CRAFTED DIRECTLY AT THEM.
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO OVER SIX
POINT THREE MILLION ASIAN AND
PACIFIC ISLANDER AMERICANS OR
SIXTEEN PERCENT OF OUR STATE
POPULATION. WHICH MANY LIVE IN
THE GREATER LOS ANGELES AREA.
EASIER TO THIRTY ONE SERVES AS A
REMINDER THAT DIVERSITY WORKS
THAT IS LAWMAKERS WE STRIVE TO
BRIDGE THE DISPARITIES AND
PROMOTE UPWARD MOBILITY EQUALITY
EMPRESS PROSPERITY FOR ALL
CONSTITUENTS THAT WE SERVE.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS BURKE.
IS THERE ANY FURTHER QUESTION TO
BAIT ON THIS MEASURE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MISTER
CHIU YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THE COMMENTS OF ALL OF OUR
COLLEAGUES IN AUS FOR YOUR
SUPPORT ON THIS AND ASK THE
FIRST WILL BE OPEN FOR COAUTHORS.
I'LL DEBATE HAVING SEIZED WE
WILL MOVE TO A VOTE ON THE
MEASURE THE FIRST ROLL CALL.
WILL BE FOR CO AUTHORS ON ACR
TWO THIRTY ONE THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE
.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE THERE
ARE SEVENTY FOUR CO AUTHORS
ADDED.
WE CAN TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THIS
ITEM ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
FOR THE FOURTEENTH ASSEMBLY
OBSERVANCE OF ASIAN AND PACIFIC
ISLANDER AMERICAN HERITAGE MONTH
WE WILL RECOGNIZE A NUMBER OF
DISTINGUISHED.
HONOREES.
I'M APPOINTING AN ESCORT
COMMITTEE.
TO BRING OUR SPECIAL GUESTS ONTO
THE FLOOR FOR A SPECIAL
PRESENTATION.
MEMBERS RETIRED TO THE REAR OF
THE CHAMBER AS I CALL YOUR NAMES.
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS SHALL.
CHEN.
DAVID CHIU.
CHOI KANSEN CHU FONG.
GLORIA.
KALRA.
LOW.
MURATSUCHI MS AREA IN.
TING AND OUR SPECIAL GUESTS
SENATORS DAILY ON.
AND PAN.
I ASKED SPEAKER ANTHONY RENDON
REPUBLICAN LEADER BRIAN DALLY
AND THE CO CHAIR OF THE JOINT
ASIAN AND PACIFIC ISLANDER
AMERICAN CAUCUS AND SPECIAL
GUEST. SENATOR JANET NGUYEN
TO JOIN ME AT THE CENTER AISLE
TO RECEIVE. OUR HONOREES.
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO THE
INTRODUCTIONS OF THE ASIAN AND
PACIFIC ISLANDER AMERICAN
HERITAGE MONTH HONOREES FOR A
TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
THE CLERK WILL READ
THE HONOREE FOR EXCELLENCE AND
ADVOCACY IS AMANDA WHEN.
SHE IS ESCORTED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS KALRA AND PHAM.
AMANDA WHEN IS THE FOUNDER AND
C. E. O. OF RISE.
CIVIL RIGHTS NONPROFIT THAT
ADVOCATES FOR THE PROTECTION OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT AND RAPE
SURVIVORS.
HER STORY OF SURVIVING SEXUAL
ASSAULT INSPIRED FORMER VICE
PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN'S PUSH FOR
THE SEXUAL ASSAULT SURVIVORS
RIGHTS ACT.
CONGRESS PASSED UNANIMOUSLY IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN.
PLEASE WELCOME THE HONOREE FOR
EXCELLENCE IN ADVOCACY MISS
AMANDA WHEN
THE HONOREES FOR EXCELLENCE IN
LITERATURE IS THE AT TIME WHEN.
HE ESCORTED BY FAMILY MEMBERS
TEAM AND ITS AREA AND SENATOR
DELEON.
YET TIME WHEN AS A VIETNAMESE
AMERICAN AUTHOR KNOWN FOR HIS
BESTSELLING PULITZER PRIZE
WINNING NOVEL THE SYMPATHIZER
ALONG WITH THE REFUGEES AND
NOTHING EVER DIES.
WHEN HIS WON CRITICAL ACCLAIM
FOR HIS DEPICTION OF ASIAN
AMERICANS DURING
A VIETNAM WAR AND SERVES AS ERA
ARNOLD CHAIR OF ENGLISH.
PROFESSOR OF ENGLISH AND
AMERICAN STUDIES AND ETHNICITY
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
PLEASE WELCOME THE HONOREE FOR
EXCELLENCE IN LITERATURE MISTER
VIA TUNNELING
.
THE HONOR READ FOR EXCELLENCE IN
PHILANTHROPY IS PEGGY THANGKA
SHE'S ESCORTED BY SOMETHING
MEMBERS MERCY JEAN KANSEN CHU.
MISS PIGGY'S SITE HAS PASSED
PRESIDENT AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF ASIAN AMERICANS AND PACIFIC
ISLANDERS IN PHILANTHROPY.
FOUNDING EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE ASIA PACIFIC ENVIRONMENTAL
NETWORK AND A FORMER DIRECTOR OF
THE ASIAN LAW CAUCUS
SHE CHAIRED THE CALIFORNIA
WELLNESS FOUNDATION AND SERVED
ON THE BOARDS OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO FOUNDATION. THE MS
FOUNDATION FOR WOMEN UNITED WAY
OF BAY AREA SUMMERSKILL MARK
FOUNDATION THE NATIONAL NETWORK
OF GRANT MAKERS AND THE COUNCIL
FOUNDATIONS.
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT SHE WAS
AWARDED THE LEADERSHIP EQUITY
AND A FIRST AWARD FROM WOMEN AND
PHILANTHROPY CELEBRATING
OUTSTANDING RISK TAKERS AND
INNOVATORS PHILANTHROPIC
COMMUNITY TO. THROUGH THEIR
DETERMINATION LEADERSHIP HAVE
INCREASED FUNDING FOR PROGRAMS
APPROVAL GENDER EQUITY AND
DIVERSITY. PLEASE WELCOME
HONOREE FOR EXPERTS IN
PHILANTHROPY IS PEGGY SEGA.
HE HONORING EXCELLENCE IN PUBLIC
SERVICE IS MAINLY TOM
SHE'S SCORED BY SOME THE NUMBER
LOW AND SENATOR PAN.
MAYBE TOM IS THE FOUNDER AND C.
E. O. OF THE PUBLIC AFFAIRS FIRM
TOM AND ASSOCIATES
AND HAS PREVIOUSLY SERVED IN THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE FOR OVER
TWENTY YEARS.
THOMAS THE FOUNDING PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER LEDGES OF LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS INSTITUTE. COFOUNDER OF
THE CAPITAL ASIAN LEGISLATIVE
STAFF CAUCUS
THE CALIFORNIA ASIAN YOUTH
LEADERSHIP PROJECT AND CO
FOUNDING CHAIR OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF ASIAN AMERICAN
INVESTMENT MANAGERS. PLEASE
WELCOME THE HONOREE FOR
EXCELLENCE PUBLIC SERVICE THIS
MAYBE TOM
.
THE HONOR READ FOR EXCELLENCE IN
SPORTS IS VINCENT JOE. HE'S
ESCORTED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBERS TOY
CHEN AND KALRA.
AT THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN OLYMPIC
WINTER GAMES TWO TIME U. S.
MEN'S MEDALIST VINCENT JOE MADE
HISTORY IN THE SHORT PROGRAM AS
THE FIRST PERSON TO LAND THE
QUADRUPLE LET'S JUMP IN OLYMPIC
COMPETITION.
HISTORY REPEATED ITSELF IN THE
FREE SKATE WHEN HE LANDED
ANOTHER QUADRUPLE LAST
IN A ROUTE.
CUT TO A TOP SIX FINISH ALTHOUGH
OPENLY AMBITIOUS JERRY MEANS
MODEST HUMBLE AND RESPECTFUL
WHEN SPEAKING OF HIS
ACHIEVEMENTS.
HE ATTRIBUTES THIS TO IS CHINESE
HERITAGE AND TO THE TRADITIONS
OF HIS PARENTS BOTH SOFTWARE
ENGINEERS TO EMIGRATE FROM CHINA.
VINCENT IS FLUENT IN MANDARIN
CHINESE AND FINISHED HIGH SCHOOL
AT AGE SIXTEEN HE WRITES POETRY
IN HIS SPARE TIME HE RECEIVED
THE PRESIDENTIAL BOARD FOR
EDUCATIONAL AT.
PLEASE WELCOME THE HONOREE FOR
EXCELLENCE IN SPORTS MISTER
VINCENT JOE
.
THE HONOREE FOR EXCELLENCE IN
BUSINESS IS RONALD LONG HE'S
ESCORTED BY SOMETHING MEMBERS
TROUT AND DAVID CHIU.
RONALD WANNA IS THE PRESIDENT
AND C. E. O. OF IMPRENTA
COMMUNICATIONS GROUP
INCORPORATED.
CALIFORNIA BASED AWARD WINNING
PUBLIC AFFAIRS AT THINK
MARKETING AND CAMPAIGN FIRM
SPECIALIZING IN REACHING DIVERSE
AUDIENCES. LONG IS THE FOUNDER
AND CREATOR OF THE ASIAN PACIFIC
AMERICAN LEADERSHIP FOUND.
OR EIGHTY ALLAH
A NONPARTISAN NONPROFIT DESIGNED
TO PREPARE ASIAN PACIFIC
AMERICAN LEADERS FOR
SERVICE AND CIVIC INVOLVEMENT.
PLEASE WELCOME THE HONOREE FOR
EXCELLENCE IN BUSINESS RONALD
LONG
.
UNABLE TO ATTEND TODAY IS THE
HONOREE EXCELLENCE IN LABOR DAVE
LOW. DAVE LOW IS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR AND DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENTAL RELATIONS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION. LOW CHAIRS THE
LABOR COALITION WHICH INCLUDES
LEGISLATIVE AND POLITICAL
REPRESENTATIVES FROM PUBLIC
EMPLOYEE UNIONS.
AND I CALIFORNIANS FOR HEALTH
CARE RETIREMENT SECURITY WHICH
REPRESENTS OVER A MILLION PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES IN CALIFORNIA AND
PENSION HEALTH CARE LABOR ISSUES
WE WELCOME THE STATE
COMMISSIONERS ON THE GOVERNOR'S
COMMISSION ON A P. AYE. AFFAIRS
THERE IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER
THEY HAVE TRAVELED ACROSS THE
STATE TO JOIN US
HERE TODAY. IN CELEBRATION OF
API HERITAGE MONTH THE
COMMISSION ON ASIAN AND PACIFIC
ISLANDER AMERICAN AFFAIRS ARE
THE ONLY ETHNIC STATE COMMISSION.
IN CALIFORNIA THESE
COMMISSIONERS ARE APPOINTEES OF
THE GOVERNOR THE SENATE.
IN THE ASSEMBLY AND I'M PLEASED
TO INTRODUCE.
THEM.
WE HAVE WITH US.
GEE. I THE TREASURER.
RAJANI THANK YOU GTR THE
TREASURER.
RAJON GIL SECRETARY.
RACHEL WHEN BE I HATE.
CATHERINE O. FERMANAGH.
MY GUY YANG.
UNA SUPER LEAGUE.
JULHO SONG.
HELEN LEAD.
SERIEN BE LOBBY SENCILLO.
POLLING LOW.
CHRISTINE MOVED.
PERFECT RAMAKRISHNAN.
WE.
I ALSO WANT TO WELCOME OUR
SPECIAL GUEST IN THE REAR
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY WHO
HAVE JOINED US FOR TWO DAYS.
CEREMONY.
THIS CONCLUDES OUR CEREMONY
LET'S GIVE THE HONOREES ANOTHER
ROUND OF APPLAUSE AS THE
DEPARTMENT OF CHANDLER. VIA THE
SENATE.
MEMBERS YOU KNOW
MEMBERS WE ARE A BUSINESS ON THE
DAILY FILE.
RECONSIDERATION ITEMS THIRTY
FOUR THROUGH THIRTY NINE.
WILL BE CONTINUED.
MEMBERS WHERE IT ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING.
FILE ITEMS.
FORTY.
THROUGH FIFTY EIGHT. THAT'S FILE
ITEMS FORTY THROUGH.
FIFTY EIGHT PASS AND RETAIN.
MEMBERS WHERE FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIFTY NINE.
MEMBERS.
VIOLATE A FIFTY NINE IS AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTY SEVEN BY MS RAY
AS THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN SIXTY
SEVEN BY SOME THE MEMBER REYES
AND ACTUALLY TO SEXUAL
HARASSMENT.
ISRAEL SHOULD YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
THE ME TOO MOVEMENT STARTED THE
CONVERSATION.
A CONVERSATION THAT IS CRUCIAL
TO A SHIFT IN CULTURE AND
MINDSET.
NOT JUST A CONVERSATION ABOUT
HOW WE CAN DO BETTER IN THIS
BUILDING BUT HOW WE MUST DO
BETTER AS A SOCIETY.
THE VOICES OF THOSE IN THE MEAT
TO MOVEMENT ARE LOUD AND CLEAR.
THE FEAR SHAME AND FRUSTRATION
OF SURVIVORS WAY ON ALL OF US
AND DEMANDED THAT WE MUST
RESPOND.
WE ARE HAVING A REAL DIALOGUE ON
HOW TO BETTER CREATE A CULTURE
OF RESPECT AND UNDERSTANDING.
HOWEVER AND A SHAMEFUL THAT IT
HAS TAKEN THIS LONG.
ME TOO DIDN'T START LAST YEAR IN
A DIDN'T START IN HOLLYWOOD NOR
THE LEGISLATURE.
IT WAS ACTUALLY FOUNDED BY
TIRANA BURKE IN TWO THOUSAND SIX.
TO HELP SURVIVORS OF SEXUAL
VIOLENCE
PARTICULARLY YOUNG WOMEN OF
COLOR FROM LOW WEALTH
COMMUNITIES.
TO FIND A PATH.
FORWARD TO HEALING.
IT IS PAST TIME FOR US TO ACT.
TO THE I PRESENT TO YOU A. B.
EIGHTEEN SIXTY SEVEN WHICH
REQUIRES THAT EMPLOYERS WITH
FIFTY OR MORE EMPLOYEES RETAIN
EMPLOYEE COMPLAINTS OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT.
FILE THROUGH THE INTERNAL
COMPLAINT PROCESS OF THE
EMPLOYER FOR A PERIOD OF TEN
YEARS FROM THE DATE OF COMPLAINT.
WE HAVE SEEN THE STORY'S OF
HARASSERS THAT HAVE BEEN ALLOWED
TO BOUNCE AROUND FROM JOB TO JOB.
SOMETIMES IN THE SAME
ORGANIZATION AND CONTINUED THE
PREDATORY BEHAVIOR.
THE RETENTION OF COMPLAIN TO
RECORDS WILL HOLD EVERYONE
ACCOUNTABLE AND ENSURE THAT
REPEAT OFFENDERS ARE NOT ABLE TO
CONTINUE VICTIMIZING OTHERS.
LASTLY MY OFFICE IS STILL IN
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE OPPOSITION
TO PROVIDE FURTHER CLARIFICATION
OF THE LANGUAGE AND DETERMINE
THE APPROPRIATE LENGTH OF TIME
FOR RETENTION OF THESE RECORDS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
I THINK IT IS REYES.
SAME KNOW ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION.
DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
COR CLUB THERE ALL. MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
.
WELL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE
.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER OUTSIDE OF AN ICE FORTY
EIGHT KNOWS NINE THEM MEASURE
PASSES.
FILE ITEM SIXTY AND SIXTY ONE.
PASS AND RETAIN WE'RE GOING TO
PASS TEMPORARILY.
ON FILE ITEM SIXTY TWO.
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE BACK
TO GAS INTRODUCTION.
I BELIEVE MISTER COOPER HAS
GUEST THAT ARRIVED IN THE
CHAMBERS MISTER COOPER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER ELECT
LOOK OF FROM MY DISTRICT THE
GULF.
HIGH SCHOOL GOT WARRIORS MEMBERS
PLEASE WELCOME ADULT WARRIORS.
MEMBERS BACK ON THE FILE FILE
ITEM SIXTY THREE AND SIXTY FOUR
PASS RETAIN OR FILE ITEM NUMBER
SO.
FIVE.
THAT IS AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY TO
BY MISTER MURATSUCHI.
CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER MURATSUCHI
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE
STATE GOVERNMENT.
MR MERCHANT SHE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS
AS A PROUD MEMBER OF THE
ASSEMBLY SURF CARCASS.
I AM STOKED TO PRESENT AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY TO. TO DECLARE
SURFING AS CALIFORNIA'S OFFICIAL
STATE SPORT.
NOTHING REPRESENTS THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM BETTER THAN
SURFING.
CATCHING THE GOLDEN WAVES OF
OPPORTUNITY AND HARM ME HARMONY
WITH OUR ENVIRONMENT.
WITH MINIMAL GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS.
SURFING WAS ORIGINALLY THE SPORT
OF HAWAIIAN ROYALTY.
SO IT IS APPROPRIATE THAT WE
ACKNOWLEDGE DURING ASIAN AND
PACIFIC ISLANDER HERITAGE MONTH
ONE OF THE GREATEST CULTURE
CONTRIBUTIONS TO OUR STATE.
BY NATIVE HAWAIIANS AND PACIFIC
ISLANDERS.
IN EIGHTEEN EIGHTY FIVE THREE
WHOLE Y. AND PRINCES.
INTRODUCED SURFING TO CALIFORNIA
AND SANTA CRUZ.
EVER SINCE THEN SERVING AS
BECOME AND ICONIC AN INTEGRAL
PART OF CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY AND
CULTURE.
SURFING DEFINES THE CALIFORNIA
STYLE.
AND THE CALIFORNIA STYLE AND
INSPIRES A MULTI BILLION DOLLAR
GLOBAL INDUSTRY.
SUPPORT FASHION TOURISM AND
RECREATION.
ALSO AN IMPORTANT PART OF
CERTAIN CALIFORNIA SURFING IS
THE METHODS OF RESPECTING AND
PROTECTING THE OCEAN. AND OUR
ENVIRONMENT.
AND SOON AS CALIFORNIA'S
RECENTLY INVENTED THE WORLD'S
BEST WAVE PARK.
AND THE CENTRAL VALLEY COMMUNITY
OF LOVE MORE.
CALIFORNIA SUPER SURFING WILL
SOON BE ENJOYED BY PEOPLE FROM
DIVERSE COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE.
THIS BILL IS SUPPORTED BY
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS WITH
NO OPPOSITION I ASK FOR YOU AYE
VOTE.
NAME IS MERCY MISTER ALAN SINCE
YOU'RE STANDING.
I VERY MUCH IS SPEAKER I LIKE
YOUR EYES WHOLEHEARTEDLY AND SAY
IT'S ABOUT TIME WE MAKE SURFING
THE OFFICIALS BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA. AS IN THE ASSEMBLY
MADE FROM HUNTINGTON BEACH SURF
CITY USA IMAX I BELIEVE THE ONLY
PERSON ON THIS LEGISLATIVE FLOOR.
YOU GOT IN THE GUINNESS BOOK OF
WORLD RECORDS FOR THE MOST
NUMBER OF SERVERS ON THE BIGGEST
SOURCE BIRD EVER BUILT. WE HAD
SIXTY SIX SERVERS ON ONE BOARD
ON THE SOUTH SIDE OF YOUR
HUNTINGTON BEACH AND I CAN TELL
YOU THAT SERVING IS TRULY V.
ICONIC CALIFORNIA SPORT. AYE I
STAND HERE WITH ALL OF MY ALSO
MY DEMOCRAT COLLEAGUES AND THIS
IS A RARE SHOW OF OF PHENOMENAL
BIPARTISANSHIP. YOU'LL
UNDERSTAND THAT.
MAJORITY LEADER CALDERON AND
MYSELF HEBOH SHARED ON A NUMBER
OF WAYS IN CALIFORNIA SERVING AT
THE RANCH AND I'LL TELL YOU THAT
NOTHING BRINGS PEOPLE TOGETHER.
LIKE HIT THE WAVES WITH A BUNCH
OF BUDDIES.
GET THE SIGN GET THE SAND AND
YES GET THAT CALIFORNIA SURF
IT'S ABOUT TIME WE MAKE THIS
OFFICIAL SPORT THANK YOU SO VERY
MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER AL MISTER
CALDERON.
TOUGH ACT TO FOLLOW TOUGH ACT TO
FOLLOW.
WELL MEMBERS AYE I THINK MOST OF
NOT IF NOT ALL OF YOU UNDERSTAND
THAT THIS IS SOMETHING THAT IS
IMPORTANT TO ME IS A SPORT THAT
I GREW UP I STARTED SURFING WHEN
I WAS SEVEN YEARS OLD.
I COMPETED US ARE COMPETING ONE
IS TEN YEARS OLD HAD MY FIRST
SPONSOR WHEN I WAS TEN YEARS OLD.
SERVER LOT OF THE MAJOR
COMPANIES THAT ALL OF US.
USUALLY BY OUR CLOTHES FROM HER
SUNGLASSES AND AND EVERYTHING
ELSE AND.
IN THERE A LOT OF FOLKS.
THAT LIKE MYSELF THIS YOU KNOW
BY PLAY BASEBALL BUT I ALSO
SERVED ITS EVERY WEEK UNITED
JUST HAVE A BASEBALL GAME I TO
SURF CONTESTS AND I GO. ATTEND
WITH MY BROTHER.
AND SO IT'S A GREAT SPORT
THERE'S A LOT OF REASONS THOUGH
OTHER THAN IT JUST BEING ABOUT
SURFING AND IT BEING.
I KNOW SOMETHING THAT IS
SYNONYMOUS WITH THE STATE AS TO
WHY THIS IS A SPORT FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE REALLY
HAVE MAINSTREAM THE SPORT. AND
WE HAVE HAD WE HAVE BEEN AND
LARGE PARTS IN IN A IN A LARGE
WAY THE ECONOMIC DRIVER. OF THIS
INDUSTRY AND YOU KNOW NOT TO
MENTION THE LOCAL ECONOMIES AYE
THAT THIS SPORT AYE DRIVES ALL
THE LOCAL ECONOMIES COASTAL
ECONOMIES THAT DEVELOP A OR
GENERATE LOTS OF REVENUE EVERY
SINGLE YEAR BECAUSE OF THE SPORT
AND IN THE INDUSTRY SURROUNDING
IT.
BUT. YOU KNOW SERVING HAS
ALWAYS BEEN.
SO SOMETHING HAS BEEN USED TO
BRIDGE GAPS BETWEEN INDIVIDUALS
AND AND.
LOWER INCOME COMMUNITIES AND
AND PROVIDING SERVE CANCER
TRYING GET INNER CITY CITY KIDS
TO PARTICIPATE IN SURFING. AND
HUMANITARIAN EFFORTS LIKE CLEAN
WATER GOING TO OTHER COUNTRIES
DISADVANTAGED COUNTRIES LIKE
INDONESIA ANOTHER FLIGHT OTHER
PLACES THAT SURFERS TEND TO
SPEND A LOT OF TIME OUT IN IN
HELPING THEM GET CLEAN WATER AND
AND AND LIFTING UP THAT
COMMUNITY BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT
SURFING IS ABOUT IT'S ABOUT LOVE.
ABOUT PASSION AND IT'S ABOUT THE
ENVIRONMENT A LOT OF THE FOLKS
THAT ARE SURFERS SPENT A LOT OF
TIME ADVOCATING FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT IN MAKING SURE THAT
WE'RE TAKING CARE. OF SOMETHING
THAT MEANS SO MUCH TO US IN FOR
AT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA YOU
KNOW OUR IDENTITY CAN BE BOILED
DOWN TO IN OUR AGRICULTURAL
INDUSTRY. IN OUR ENTERTAINMENT
INDUSTRY.
AND SURFING.
I AND AND SO I REALLY FEEL LIKE
THIS IS A SPORT THAT DESERVES
RECOGNITION AS BEING OUR STATE
SPORT NOW YOU COULD ALWAYS HAVE
YOUR INDIVIDUAL SPORT IF ANY AND
ENTERPRISING MEMBERS WANTED TO
DESIGNATE A. AN INDIVIDUAL SPORT
A POTENTIALLY A TEAM SPORT YOU
CAN ALWAYS YOU CAN ALWAYS.
FIGURE THAT OUT IF THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WAS IMPORTANT TO
YOU A BUT THIS IS SO MUCH MORE
THAN JUST ABOUT A SERVING OF
THIS FOR WHAT YOU DO IT OR NOT
IT'S A HUGE BENEFIT ECONOMIC
BENEFIT TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND A LOT OF PEOPLE.
.
DO A LOT OF GREAT WORK FOR
OTHERS AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES THROUGH THIS FOR AND
AGAIN THIS ISN'T JUST A COASTAL
THING. GREAT IS ARGUABLY THE ONE
OF THE BEST WAYS NOW IN THE
WORLD IS IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
CALIFORNIA'S CENTRAL VALLEY IN
THAT COUNTRY IN THE CITY OF LA
MORE. AND.
MY GOOD COLLEAGUES DISTRICT
THAT REPRESENTS BAKERSFIELD SO I
I I WOULD REALLY URGE YOU TO
CONSIDER THIS MEASURE IT IS AN
IMPORTANT MEASURE IT'S IT'S PART
OF OUR IDENTITY IS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
FAMOUS CALDERON MISTER HARPER
DIRECTOR THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE
TODAY. I REPRESENTING LAGUNA
BEACH NEWPORT BEACH AND
HUNTINGTON BEACH.
ON BEING THE FORMER MAYOR OF
SURF CITY USA HUNTINGTON BEACH A
I WANT TO SAY A LITTLE BIT OF
BACKGROUND.
THE YEAR THAT I SERVED AS MAYOR
OF HUNTINGTON BEACH A ONE AND
THINGS THAT I DID THAT BROUGHT
PEOPLE TOGETHER AND WAS A
POSITIVE CELEBRATION WITH OUR
CITY WAS CELEBRATING. ONE
HUNDRED YEARS OF SURFING WITHIN
THE CITY HUNTINGTON BEACH
WE HAD BEEN ONE HUNDRED YEARS
SINCE GEORGE FREE. HAD BROUGHT
HIS WOODEN SURFBOARD TO THE
HUNTINGTON BEACH PIER A TO BE
ABLE TO DEMONSTRATE SERVING
RIGHT OFF WITHOUT A LINE THAT
HENRY HUNTINGTON BUILT A FOR THE
RED CAR. AYE SO WHY WITH THAT.
I WANT TO SAY THAT I AM IN FULL
SUPPORT FOR THE MEMBER FROM
TORRANCE IS BILL.
FOR.
THIS AYE VOTE TODAY.
THANK YOU MISTER HARPER.
IT'S YOUR SALAS YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKERS
MEMBERS I THINK IT'S BEEN
ALLUDED TO A COUPLE TIMES RUN
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT. OF FILE
ITEM NUMBER SIXTY FIVE AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY TWO. FOR WORLD
SURFING DAY.
THE BEST WAVES IN CALIFORNIA
ACTUALLY ENGINEERED A LOT MORE
CALIFORNIA.
SO IT'S NO WHERE ALONG THE COAST.
WHEN A REPEAT THAT AGAIN INLAND
CALIFORNIA NO WERE ALONG THE
COAST IS A BOAST ENGINEER.
PERFECTLY PERFECTED WAVE.
IS COMING FROM MY PART OF THE
DISTRICT.
SO I THOUGHT THAT WAS JUST AN
INTERESTING TIDBIT FOR EVERYBODY
THAT NOW I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS. AND DESPITE OUR MAJORITY
LEADER BEING A PASSED
COMPETITIVE SURFER AND I URGE
YOU ALL TO RESIST YOUR URGES.
BUT VOTE I.
THANK YOU SALAS MR MATHIS YOUR
RECOMMEND.
I'M MEMBERS. WELL WHY DON'T
OPPOSE THE SPORT A SURFING IN IS
ALWAYS A GREAT TIME TO GO HANG
TEN.
I I GOT A STAND IN OPPOSITION.
AS A PROUD INLAND SKATEBOARDER.
OF THE TRUE HERITAGE OF OUR
STATE IS SKATEBOARDING. OF WHICH
STARTED DOES FAR BACK AS THE
NINETEEN FIFTIES IN OUR STATE.
AND.
WAIT WHEN OUR FOREFATHERS.
OF THE BOARD DECIDED TO START.
SKATING THE CONCRETE HILLS.
SO WE'RE TRULY GOING TO PAY
RESPECT TO OUR STATE MEMBERS ASK
YOU TO OPPOSE THIS OR TAKE SOME
AMENDMENTS OR SOMETHING. BECAUSE
SKATEBOARDING IS TRULY THE
STATE'S POOR.
SO STAND WITH ME OPPOSE SKATER
DIE.
MISTER GALLAGHER. YOUR RECKLESS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
VERY INTRIGUING DEBATE BUT I I
THINK I WOULD BE REMISS IF I DID
MAKE THE CASE.
FOR BASEBALL ALRIGHT.
NOW.
MANY OF YOU KNOW BASEBALL IS
AMERICA'S PASTIME BUT I WOULD
ARGUE.
IT'S BEEN GREATLY IMPROVED BY
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
NOW WE JUST BRING UP A COUPLE OF
POINTS. THAT DIMAGGIO BROTHERS
FROM SAN FRANCISCO.
TO THE GAME'S GREATEST HITTERS
TED WILLIAMS AND TONY GWYNN FROM
SAN DIEGO.
TOM NOT TO MENTION THIS THREE
TIME WORLD CHAMPION THIS DECADE
SAN FRANCISCO GIANTS.
ARE. WE HAVE TO MAKE THE CASE
THEY CALIFORNIA'S GREATLY
IMPRESSED NOTHING BRINGS
TOGETHER.
ALL PARTS OF CALIFORNIA I I
UNDERSTAND YOU GUYS SIR FULL ON
THE COAST.
WHAT ABOUT FOR THOSE OF US AND
THEN AND I I KNOW ABOUT THE
ARTIFICIAL WAVES CREATED THAT'S
GREAT?
BUT WHERE YOU CAN PLAY BASEBALL
ANYWHERE. ALL ACROSS THIS GREAT
STATE. AND SO I WOULD MAKE THE
CASE JACKIE ROBINSON.
UCLA GRAD.
INTEGRATED THE GAME OF BASEBALL
BASEBALL IN CALIFORNIA.
HAS BEEN GREAT IS BARELY BEEN
IMPROVED UPON BY CALIFORNIANS
AND BASEBALL SHOULD BE OUR STATE
SPORT.
BUT THAT I WILL CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER GALLAGHER.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE.
MISTER MURATSUCHI.
HE'D LIKE TO ADDRESS YEAH.
YOU'RE CLOSE TO THE ASSEMBLY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
APPRECIATE ALL THE ROBUST DEBATE
AND CONVERSATION OVER THIS VERY
IMPORTANT BILL.
TO. MY COLLEAGUE FROM BY SALIA.
I WOULD LIKE TO RESPOND.
THAT WHILE WITH NO DO.
DISRESPECT FOR SKATEBOARDERS.
SKATEBOARDING WAS INSPIRED BY
SURFING.
SKATEBOARDING IS.
ON LAND SURFING.
WE'VE HAD.
I WIDE RANGE OF PROPOSALS AS TO
WHAT SHOULD BE CALIFORNIA'S.
OFFICIAL STATE SPORT. I HAD ONE
WOMAN CALLING ON A RADIO TALK
SHOW SAYING THAT. IT SHOULD BE
WALKING
BECAUSE EVERYONE CAN DO WALKING.
YOU KNOW BASEBALL THE LIST CAN
GO ON AND ON.
BUT AGAIN NOTHING MORE ICONIC.
TO THE CALIFORNIA BRAND THAN
SURFING.
LET'S SUPPORT THE CALIFORNIA
BRAMLETT SUPPORT THE CALIFORNIA
STYLE. AND LET'S RIDE THE BIG
BLUE WAVE OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
WITH THAT.
MISTER OUT WERE IN THE CLOSE
WHERE MISTER SPEAKER.
MISTER SPEAKER IT WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT POINT OF PERSONAL
PRIVILEGE I BELIEVE THERE'S A
RED TIDE CAN MEAN CALIFORNIA
RIGHT NOW.
YOU BOTH TOOK MY JOBS OPEN THE
ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERS ABOUT HIS ART ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
IT IS OUT OF THE.
CLARK WELL CLOSE THE ROLE. I
SIXTY KNOWS THREE THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION WE ARE
GOING TO MOVE TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE OF SIX THAT'S HR ONE
NO SEVEN.
BY MISS FRIEDMAN FOR THE PURPOSE
OF THIRD READING.
THE CLERK WILL READ.
HOUSE RESOLUTION ONE OH SEVEN BY
SOME REMEMBER FRIEDMAN OF
RELATIVE TO THE SEVENTIETH
ANNIVERSARY OF THE FOUNDING OF
THE STATE OF ISRAEL.
MISS FRIEDMAN YOU MAY OPEN THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS.
I RISE TODAY TO INTRODUCE HR ONE
OF SEVEN IN CELEBRATION OF THE
SEVEN SEVENTIETH ANNIVERSARY OF
THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE STATE OF
ISRAEL.
THE HISTORY OF ISRAEL AND THE
JEWISH PEOPLE GOES BACK TWO
THOUSAND YEARS AND IT IS AN AREA
WHERE MANY MAINTAIN A PROFOUND
SPIRITUAL AND EMOTIONAL
CONNECTION TO THAT LAND.
DIPLOMATIC RELATIONS WITH ISRAEL
HAS BROUGHT GREAT TURMOIL IN
CHAOS TO THE REGION YET ISRAEL
REMAINS A REGIONAL PARTNER FOR
THE UNITED STATES SINCE NINETEEN
FORTY NINE. AT A CULTURAL
CAPITAL FOR THE JEWISH PEOPLE.
JUST A FEW WEEKS AGO IN LATE
APRIL A DELEGATION OF UN
AMBASSADORS FROM AROUND THE
WORLD TOOK PART IN CELEBRATIONS
MARKING ISRAEL SEVENTIETH YEAR
OF AND THE.
AMBASSADORS FROM EUROPE LATIN
AMERICA AND AFRICA PARTICIPATED
IN CELEBRATE TERRY EVENTS TO
HONOR THIS REMARKABLE
ANNIVERSARY FOR ISRAEL.
IN THE SAME TIME PERIOD FIVE
THOUSAND ISRAELI FLAG SIGNED BY
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND WELL WISHES
FROM ALL AROUND THE WORLD WERE
PLACED IN A TIME CAPSULE.
THE FLAGS CONTAIN BLESSINGS AND
WISHES OF CHILDREN SOLDIERS
CULTURAL AND SPIRITUAL LEADERS
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS AMBASSADORS
AND OTHERS FROM ISRAEL. AS WELL
AS NEW DELHI ROOM SAN FRANCISCO
BUCHAREST COPENHAGEN SAN PAULO
AMBITION AVERAGE AND MIAMI
SERBIA MOSCOW SEOUL TOKYO AND
OTHER CITIES.
THE PROJECT CALLED ASCENDING THE
FLAG.
WAS TO SHOW THAT ISRAEL'S FLAG
IS NOT JUST ABOUT DEATH AND
BATTLEFIELDS BUT ABOUT OUR
NATION'S FUTURE ABOUT ITS LIFE.
THE CURATOR OF THE PROJECT ALONG
BLOOD STATE STATES TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND BLESSING US CANNOT GO
WRONG.
LET US CELEBRATE THE STATE OF
ISRAEL SEVENTEENTH ANNIVERSARY
AS REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE OUR BLESSINGS ALSO
CANNOT GO WRONG.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
CALIFORNIA AND ISRAEL HAVE HAD A
MEMORANDUM OF UNDERSTANDING
WHICH ESTABLISHES A FORMAL
RELATIONSHIP TO FOSTER ECONOMIC
COOPERATION AND DEVELOPMENT.
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES JOB
CREATION AND INCUBATE GLOBAL
SOLUTIONS.
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO A VIBRANT
ISRAELI AMERICAN IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITY AND EXPANSIVE JEWISH
NETWORK.
AS ELECTED REPRESENTATIVES OF
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA IT IS
OUR DUTY TO STAND UP AGAINST
INTOLERANCE AND BIGOTRY AND TO
CLARIFY THE FACTS AND EVENTS OF
THE MANY CULTURES THAT WE
REPRESENT.
ISRAEL ISRAEL CONTINUES TO
STRUGGLE TO FIND PEACE AND
SECURITY WHAT A CELEBRATE THEIR
DEVELOPMENT OF SEVENTY YEARS AS
A SOVEREIGN STATE. AND THE
CONTINUATION OF HOPE FOR A
PEACEFUL FUTURE FOR ISRAEL.
HR ONE OF SEVEN CENTS ARE BEST
WISHES FOR A PEACEFUL AND
PROSPEROUS FUTURE FOR THE STATE
OF ISRAEL AND I THANK YOU ALL
FOR YOUR SUPPORT. MISTER SPEAKER
I REQUEST OF THE FIRST WILL BE
OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS.
NAMES FRIEDMAN SEEN NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE RESOLUTION DOCTOR CHOI YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND UP
MEMBERS SIDE RISE AGAIN IN
SUPPORT OF LAW.
H. H. OUT ONE OR SEVEN.
TODAY I RISE OF.
TO SUPPORT THIS AYE IMPORTER NOT
A MAJOR FOR THIS ROUTE TO
RECOGNIZE.
AND I CONGRATULATE THE THE
PEOPLE UP ISRAEL ON THE LOCATION
OF THE.
.
THE COUNTRY OF OUR IS ROSA SEVEN
FIFTH ANNIVERSARY. I S. OF KOREA
OR SO WOULD BE CELEBRATING IN
AUGUST FIFTEENTH ARE AS SO IS SO
SEVENTY THIRD DOOR.
INDEPENDENCE THE.
THIS YEAR. ISRAEL HAS SO COME.
ACCOMPLISHED MANY REMARKABLE
ACHIEVEMENTS
ARE SOME OF WHICH INCLUDE THAT
ISRAEL HAS TO YEAH THIRD.
HIGHEST A RATE OF OUR. OUR
ENTREPRENEURSHIP AND A START UP
COMPANIES IN THE WORD DOC AND
THE HIGHEST. RATE AMONG WOMEN
AND ARE AMONG PEOPLE OVER FIFTY
FIVE BUT IN THE WORD.
ISRAEL HAS THE HIGHEST A NUMBER
OF WHAT YOU'VE LISTED DEGREES SO
PER CAPITA THAN NOT ANY OTHER
COUNTRY.
THIS ROD IS THE ONLY COUNTRY TO
HAVE DR ALL. MORE TREES TODAY
THAN IT DID THE FIFTY SI GOAL
WHAT ABOUT THAT.
AND THE LIST GOES ON THE MOST
DISTANT SIGNIFICANT FACT.
ABOUT THE OUR NATION OF WHAT
ISRAEL IS THAT THEY REMAIN IN
OUR MOST. IMPORTANT ALLY IN THE
MIDDLE EAST.
I JOIN UP WITH SO MANY.
AS TEAM THE COLLEAGUES
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF FROM OUT
THEN THEY'LL IN. RECOGNIZING
THIS IMPORTANT DAY AND I'M NOT
ALSO.
RECOGNIZE. THAT TODAY IS THE
HISTORIC.
DAY YEAH BECAUSE SOUGHT THAT
THE YACHT DIRECTION ALTHOUGH
PRESTON ON DONALD TRUMP
THE UNITED STATES ARE HAS SO
OPEN THAT IS TAUGHT EMBASSY IN
JERUSALEM. ALSO RECOGNIZING AT
THE BEST A CAPITAL OF THE NATION
OF.
ISRAEL THANK YOU FOR YOUR BY.
RESPECT THE OLD YOU I'VE WORKED.
SAY NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
DEBATE.
MS THREE MS ASSET THE FIRST ROLE
BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
HOUSE RESOLUTION.
COR CLUB THERE ALL AMBITIOUS IS
CO AUTHORS.
CO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
ARE CO AUTHORS MEMBERS.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE RATHER SEVENTY ONE CO
AUTHORS ADDED THEM WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE HOUSE RESOLUTION ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED AND MISS FRIEDMAN.
RECOGNIZING YOU FROM MY DESK ON
THE FLOOR FOR YOUR GUEST
INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
BUT ISRAELI CYCLONE THEM ISRAEL
SEVENTIETH ANNIVERSARY PLEASE
JOIN ME IN WELCOMING VERY
SPECIAL GAS CONSUL GENERAL
SHLOMI KAUFMAN DEPUTY CONSUL
GENERAL RUGBY FAIR. AND RUN THE
RUN THAT AGENT.
THANK YOU
MEMBERS WE HAVE SOME ADDITIONAL
GAS WITH US IN THE CHAMBER
MISTER LEVINE I'M RECOGNIZE YOU
FROM MISTER CALDERON JUST ASK
FOR YOUR GUESTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I AM
DELIGHTED TO WELCOME TWENTY
EIGHT FOURTH GRADERS FROM HIDDEN
VALLEY ELEMENTARY SCHOOL UP
THERE IN THE GALLERY. THERE WITH
MISS ISAAC INNER AND THEIR
CHAPERONES AND I JUST WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU MISS AYE SINGER
FOR ALL OF YOUR HARD WORK.
I KNOW YOU'RE RETIRING SOON SO
THANK YOU FOR BRING IN A CLASS
APPEAR TO SACRAMENTO THIS YEAR
LET'S WELCOME THEM ALL UP HERE
PAID HERE.
MEMBERS BACK ON THE FILE.
WE ARE AT FILE ITEM.
WE'RE GOING TO RETURN TO FILE
ITEM SIXTY TWO THIS IS FILE ITEM
SIXTY TWO.
AB TWENTY SEVEN NINETY NINE BY
MISTER JONES SAWYER CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVEN
NINETY NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JONES SAWYER AND EXPLAINED
CANNABIS.
MISTER JONES SAWYER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TO RESENT AB TWENTY SEVEN NINETY
NINE WHICH WOULD REQUIRE AN
APPLICANT FOR CANADA SLICE IT
PROVIDE A STATEMENT ALONG WITH
THEIR APPLICATION.
AFFIRMING THAT THEY WILL ENSURE
THAT AT LEAST ONE SUPERVISOR AND
ONE EMPLOYEE RECEIVED TRAINING
FROM PALO SHIP.
PACIFIC LEE JUST BILL WERE
REQUIRED EMPLOYEES COMPLETE THE
CAL OSHA THIRTY HOURS GENERAL
INDUSTRY TRAINING WITHIN ONE
YEAR OF THE CANVAS APPLICANT
RECEIVING THEIR LICENSE. THIS
WOULD ENSURE THAT THE CANVAS
INDUSTRY ADHERES TO THE SAME
SAFETY STANDARDS THAT OTHER
INDUSTRIES.
THIS BILL HAS NO NO NOT
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
THREE AYE VOTE.
THEY WERE SHOWS WHERE.
SEEING.
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLARK WELL OPEN THE ROLL-ON ALL
MEMBERS VOTE. DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
THIS TAKES FIFTY FOUR.
IT'S TAKES FIFTY FOR ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
STATE FIFTY FOUR
FARKLE CLOSER ROLE. TALLIED
ABOUT EYES FIFTY FOUR.
KNOWS TWENTY.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM SIXTY SEVEN PASS AND
RETAIN
.
MEMBERS WHERE FILE ITEM SIXTY
SIX THIS IS SIXTY SIX.
AB TWENTY NINE SIX.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINE SIXTY
NINE BY SOME THE MEMBER LOW AND
OTHERS AN ACTUAL LINK LGBT PRIDE
MONTH.
SURE LOW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MS SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS AB TWENTY NINE SIXTY
NINE ESTABLISHES THE MONTH OF
JUNE AS LGBT PRIDE MONTH IN
CODIFIES IN STATUTE. OF THIS
IMPORTANT THE MONTH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THEY IT WAS A LOVE SCENE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
QUIRK LIBERAL. MEMBERS VOTED
WITHOUT A VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TIED ABOUT ICE FIFTY
EIGHT NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
MEMBERS WERE FILE ITEM NUMBER
SIXTY EIGHT.
AB SEVENTEEN NINETY SEVEN
CORPORAL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN NINETY
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE
AND OTHERS ACTUALLY TO INSURANCE.
MR LEVINE YOU MAY OPEN.
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS SIDE
THIS LEGISLATION WILL HELP A LOT
A HOMEOWNERS IN THE FUTURE BY
MAKING SURE THEIR HOMES HAVE THE
THE AMOUNT OF INSURANCE THAT
THEY NEED BUT WE FOUND AFTER THE
WILD FIRES. THIS PAST FALL WAS
THAT MANY OF THE SURVIVORS WERE
VICTIMS ALSO OF UNDER INSURANCE
AND THIS WOULD REQUIRE THAT
INSURANCE CARRIERS OFFER AND
EVERY OTHER YEAR AND OPPORTUNITY
TO TELL INSURED PEOPLE WHAT IT
WOULD ACTUALLY COST. TO REPLACE
THEIR HOME IT IS THEN A CHOICE
OF FOR THE HOMEOWNER TO DECIDE
IF THEY WANT TO PURCHASE THAT
MUCH INSURANCE ARE EXPECT WE ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
YOU MISS LIVING SENIOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLICK LIBERAL I'M.
IT IS SAD ABOUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DECIDED THOUGH.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ALL TIED ABOUT I SEVENTY
FIVE NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEMS SIXTY NINE.
THROUGH SEVENTY TWO.
PASS AND RETAIN.
THAT BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM
SEVENTY THREE. AB TWENTY EIGHT
FORTY FOUR BY MISTER COOLEY
COOPER READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT FORTY
FOUR BY FAMILY MEMBER COOLEY AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO INSURANCE.
MISTER COOLEY.
GOOD AFTERNOON COLLEAGUES I RISE
TO SUPPORT ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
EIGHT FORTY FOUR.
SPILL SPECIFIES THAT THE TERM
SERVER A BRITON COMMISSION
AGREEMENT.
BETWEEN ENSURING A BROKER ARE
SUPPORTED BY REBUTTABLE
PRESUMPTION.
GOOD THEY ARE VALID.
WELL AS LONG AS A COMPLAINER
SPECIFIED PROVISIONS OF THE
JURORS CODE IN THE WRITTEN
AGREEMENT ITSELF.
SUPPORTS COMMERCIAL REACHABILITY.
OF COURSE IS REBUTTABLE
PRESUMPTION CAN ALWAYS BE
OVERCOME BY CONTRARY EVIDENCE
IRA DRIVE VOTE.
THEY WAS COOLEY SEEING THEIR
DISCRETION MADE ON THE ITEM
QUIRK LOVE IN THE WRONG. ON
MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ZERO.
AND HOW THE I SIX NINE DOES ONE
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM SEVENTY FOUR PASS
RETAIN.
FILE ITEM SEVENTY FIVE IS AB
TWENTY NINE TWENTY.
CORPORATE ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
NINE TWENTY BY FAMILY MEMBER
THURMOND AND ACTUALLY THE
TAXATION.
MR THURMAN YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS ARE RISE TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY NINE TWENTY.
THIS IS A DISTRICT BILL THAT
ALLOW THE CITY OF BERKELEY
SHOULD THEY CHOOSE TO TO
INCREASE SALES TAX TO GENERATE
REVENUE.
SUPPORT PROGRAMS TO HELP THE
HOMELESS INTO SUPPORT THEIR
COMMUNITY POLICING PROGRAMS AND
TO EXPAND MENTAL HEALTH PROGRAMS.
IF PASSED BY VOTERS
SALES TAX WILL INCREASE BY NO
MORE THEM POINT FIVE PERCENT.
BUT IT WOULD REQUIRE STATUTORY
APPROVAL BY THIS BODY TO PUT IT
ON THE BALLOT IN THE CITY OF
BERKELEY.
THE LEGISLATOR HAS GRANTED
SEVERAL SIMILAR EXEMPTIONS.
TO SEVERAL COUNTIES I IN THE
AREA IN THE CITY OF BERKELEY NOW
WISHES TO DO THE SAME THING.
THIS BILL IS ONE LOCAL SOLUTION
WHILE WE CONTINUE TO WORK ON
STATEWIDE SOLUTIONS TO ADDRESS
CHALLENGES LIKE HOMELESS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON AB TWENTY NINE TWENTY.
THANK MUCH THURMOND MISTER ALLEN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
IS THERE A POINT AT WHICH THE
CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATS SAY ENOUGH
TAXES ARE ENOUGH.
MISTER CALDERON STAGE POINT OF
ORDER IT IS CUSTOMARY THAT WHEN
YOU ARE REFERRING.
TO THE OTHER.
MEMBERS THAT ARE NOT PART OF
YOUR PARTY THAT YOU SAY MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE OTHER SIDE OF
THE AISLE IS NOT DIFFERENTIATED
BETWEEN DEMOCRAT OR REPUBLICAN.
THIS IS A RESPECTFUL BODY WHEN
WE HAVE RESPECT EVERYBODY'S
IDEAS AND SO I ASK THAT WHEN WE
ARE ADDRESSING MEMBERS FROM THE
OTHER PARTY. WE RESPECTFULLY SAY
AS AS AS IS TRADITION ON THIS
FLOOR THAT WE REFER TO THEM AS
THE COLLEAGUES ON THE OTHER SIDE
OF THE AISLE.
THEY WAS CALDERON THE POINT OF
ORDER IS WELL TAKEN WITH REGARD
TO CIVILITY AND RESPECT ON THE
FLOOR THE ASSEMBLY.
HOW MISTER ALLEN YOU MAY PROCEED
I THINK GROCERS ARE LIKE TO
ADDRESS OF MY COLLEAGUES RIHA
COMMENT? I ACTUALLY I'LL TELL
YOU RIGHT NOW THAT THIS FLOOR
HAS PASSED FOR BEYOND CIVILITY.
AND IT'S ABOUT TIME WE ACTIONS
CALL THINGS WHAT THEY ARE HERE
IN THE CALIFORNIA HILL HERE IN
THE IN THE LEGISLATURE. THIS IS
THE PEOPLE'S HOUSE LAYS JOHN
THIS IS THE REPRESENTATION OF
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA SO NO I
WON'T SAVE MY COLLEAGUES
MILITARY I'LL I'M GONNA SAY
CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATS. BECAUSE
LET'S BE CLEAR WE ARE
REPUBLICANS OR DEMOCRATS ON THE
MISTER CALDERON.
STAGE POINT WHERE AGAIN.
WE KEEPING WITHIN THE TRADITIONS
OF THIS BODY THAT WE'VE ALWAYS
FOLLOWED SO I ASK THE MEMBER
RESPECT THAT TRADITION HOWEVER.
I ALSO ASK THAT THE MEMBERS. TO
THE BILL.
IT IS NOT.
A GOOD USE OF OUR TIME THAT
EVERY TIME OUR GOOD COLLEAGUE
FROM HUNTINGTON BEACH STANDS UP
WE GET A CAMPAIGN SPEECH THAT'S
NOT WHAT THIS IS FOR WE'RE HERE
TO TALK ABOUT A BILL. HE NEEDS
TO SPEAK TO THE BILL IN CHIEF
AND ABOUT THAT ONLY AND NOTHING
BEYOND THAT.
CALDERON. I DID.
RULE ON THE PREVIOUS POINT OF
ORDER SAID THAT. WHEN WORK
CONTINUES TO BE WELL TAKEN I
WOULD ALSO.
TAKE YOUR ADDITIONAL POINT.
AS WELL TAKEN THAT WE ARE GOING
TO REFRAIN FROM COMMENTS BEYOND
THE SCOPE OF THE BILL BEFORE THE
BODY. MR OUT YOU MAY CONTINUE
REGARDING THE CONTENTS OF THE
BILL BEFORE THE BODY YES THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I RISE ON BEHALF
OF EVERY SINGLE CITIZEN IN THE
CITY OF BERKELEY.
THEY PAYS INCREDIBLE AMOUNTS OF
TAX
THERE TO PAY THE HIGHEST TAXES
INCOME TAX IN THE NATION. THEY
PAY THE HIGHEST SALES TAXES IN
THE NATION THEY PIPE PAY ONE OF
THE HIGHEST GAS TAXES IN THE
COUNTRY AND THEY NEVER GOT A
CHANCE TO VOTE ON THIS GAS TAX.
THEY ALSO PAY ONE THE HIGHEST
CORPORATE TAX IN THE WHOLE
COUNTRY NOW.
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE.
WANTS TO ASSESS THEM AND GIVE
THEM THE ABILITY TO RAISE YOUR.
YET AGAIN.
I'LL TELL YOU RIGHT NOW THAT
THERE IS ONLY ONE ELECTED MEMBER
FROM THE CITY OF BERKELEY HERE
ON THE FLOOR TODAY. THE REST OF
THE CITIZENS OF BERKELEY ARE NOT
REPRESENTED. AND SO AS A
CALIFORNIA ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHO
REPRESENTS NOT ONLY MY OWN
DISTRICT BUT EVERY CITIZEN IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AYE RICE
FOR ALL OF THOSE VOICES
CALIFORNIANS THAT DON'T WANT
THEIR TAX RATES.
THESE PEOPLE DO NOT HAVE A
CHOICE WHEN THIS LEGISLATURE
RAISE THE GAS TAX
YOU ARE NOW TELLING THEM THE
YOU'RE AUTHORIZING YET ANOTHER
SALES TAX INCREASE FOR THESE
PEOPLE. YES IT WOULD HAVE TO GO
THROUGH BY LOCAL STATUTE BUT THE
CAP WAS ALREADY SAID IT TWO
PERCENT NOW YOU'RE ASKING FOR
YET ANOTHER INCREASE. THIS TIME
OF HALF A PERCENT I ASK A VERY
SIMPLE QUESTION WHY HAVE PERCENT.
WHY NOT YOU SHOW ALL YOUR CARDS
AND SAY THAT THERE SHOULD BE
LIMITLESS TAX INCREASES FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS AND WE WILL LET
THEM RAISE IT AS MUCH AS THEY
WANT? BECAUSE THAT IS WHAT THE
ACTIONS.
OF TODAY'S CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATS
HAVE STATED I WILL STATE VERY
CLEARLY THAT THIS IS A BAD BILL.
AYE VOTE AGAINST EVERY SINGLE
TAX INCREASE IN THIS IS YET
ANOTHER OPEN THIS ANOTHER
OPENING FOR YET ANOTHER TAX
INCREASE IN THE HARD WORKING
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. IT MUST
STOP SOMETIME LEASING GOVERNMENT
AT SOME POINT REGARDS A
POLITICAL PARTY YOU HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND THAT ENOUGH IS ENOUGH.
THE CALIFORNIA GOVERNOR'S HE'S
MORE TAX REVIEW THE NEVER HOUSE
AND OUR LOCAL CITIES ARE TAXING
THEIR RESIDENTS MORE THAN THEY
EVER HAVE. WHY THESE RESIDENTS
WANT THEIR TAXES RAISED EVEN
FURTHER ABOUT TIME WE STAND UP
FOR THE LITTLE GUY IN CALIFORNIA
ABOUT TIME WE STAND UP AND SAY?
NO MORE TAX INCREASE IN
CALIFORNIA LET'S START CUTTING
OUR TAXES.
INSTEAD OF RAISING THEM.
I URGE NO VOTE.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
DEBATE. ON THE BILL.
MR THURMAN YOU MAY CLOSE THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES AND TO MY GOOD
COLLEAGUE.
FROM HUNTINGTON BEACH I
APPRECIATE YOUR PASSION.
YOU ARE WELCOME ANYTIME THAT YOU
WISH TO JOIN OUR CITIZENRY IN
THE CITY OF BERKELEY. WE'D LOVE
TO HAVE YOU IT WOULD BE MY HONOR
ON BEHALF OF THE PEOPLE OF
BERKELEY TO REPRESENT YOU AS
WELL.
PLEASE KNOW.
THAT THE MEASURE BEFORE YOU.
IS NEITHER ATTACKS.
OR STATEMENT ABOUT PARTY.
CITY OF BERKELEY MAY HAVE MORE
POLITICAL PARTIES THAN ANY CITY.
IN OUR STATE.
THIS IS SIMPLY AN OPPORTUNITY AT
THE REQUEST.
OF MANY OF THE SECURE OF THE
CONSTITUENTS IN THE CITY TO PUT
BEFORE THE CITIZENS THE QUESTION
WOULD YOU LIKE TO INCREASE YOUR
SALES TAX. AS AT LEAST TEN OTHER
JURISDICTIONS HAVE BEEN GRANTED
THE RIGHT TO DO IN THIS STATE TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUES OF
HOMELESSNESS ON BEHALF OF THE
PEOPLE OF BERKELEY I
FAMOUS THURMOND AND WITH THAT
CLERK LIBERAL. AND VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTE THIS OUT OF THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THOSE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TIED ABOUT ICE FORTY
SEVEN KNOWS TWENTY SEVEN THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM SEVENTY SIX PASS
RETAIN.
WE ARE FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVENTY
SEVEN.
AB THIRTY NINETEEN CORKERY.
SOME LEGAL THIRTY NINETEEN BY
SOME REMEMBER REYES AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY THE DEPOSITIONS.
MS RACE. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS TODAY AND
PRESENTING AB THREE ZERO ONE
NINE A TECHNICAL BILL WHICH
REQUIRES ALL NOTICES THE WORLD
DEPOSITION. TO BE IN TWELVE
POINT FONT FOR RE READABILITY.
EXISTING LAW ALREADY REQUIRES A
PARTY'S DESIRING TO TAKE ALL
DEPOSITIONS FROM ANY PERSON TO
GIVE WRITTEN NOTICE OF THE
DEPOSITION TO THAT PERSON. THIS
BILL SIMPLY INSURES THAT THE
NOTICE OF DEPOSITION ALONG WITH
THE ALREADY REQUIRED INFORMATION
IS IN AT LEAST TWELVE POINT FONT.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTES.
THANK YOU MS RACINO DISCUSSION
DEBATE.
CLICK LIBERAL. MEMBERS VOTE.
THE SAD ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLE ANTI OF AN
ICE FIFTY FIVE NO SIX
THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM
SEVENTY EIGHT.
THROUGH EIGHTY THREE.
PASS A RETAIN FILE ITEM EIGHTY
FOUR. IS A BE TWENTY EIGHT
NINETEEN COOPERATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINETEEN BY
SOME A NUMBER AGUIAR-CURRY AND
ACTUALLY THE HEALTH CARE
DISTRICTS.
MS AGUIAR-CURRY.
MEMBERS AB TWENTY NINETEEN BILLS
ON THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE'S BILL FROM LAST YEAR
WHICH ESTABLISH SOME VERY BASIC
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
REQUIREMENTS FOR HEALTH CARE
DISTRICTS.
IN CALIFORNIA.
AB TWENTY NINETEEN REQUIRES
HELPED HER DISTRICTS TO POST
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION ON THEIR
WEBSITES.
INCLUDING THEIR ANNUAL BUDGETS
BOARD MEMBERS FINANCIAL REPORTS
AUDITS GRANT POLICIES AND
RECIPIENTS OF GRANT FUNDING.
AB TWENTY NINETEEN ALSO FLESHES
OUT THE REQUIREMENTS OF HEALTH
THEIR KILLER DISTRICTS
GRAMPS GRANDPA HE'S RECOGNIZING
THE TWENTY PERCENT. OF HEALTH
CARE DISTRICTS ENGAGE IN NO
OTHER ACTIVITY OUTSIDE OF
AWARDING GRANTS.
THE GOAL IS TO ENSURE THE
DISTRICTS FULLY CONSIDER THEIR
GUIDELINES IN AWARDING GRANTS
AND MAKE THOSE GUIDELINES
AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC.
AB TWENTY NINETEEN ALSO REQUIRES
HEALTH CARE DISTRICTS TO NOTIFY
THE RESPECTIVE LOCAL AGENCY
FORMATION COMMISSION WHEN FILING
FOR BANKRUPTCY. IN RESPONSE TO
THE NUMBER OF DISTRICTS THAT
HAVE ALREADY DECLARED BANKRUPTCY.
FINALLY EV AB TWENTY NINETEEN
REQUIRES TWENTY PERCENT SET
ASIDE FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
UNITS. IF HEALTH CARE DISTRICTS
USE DESIGN BUILD TO CONSTRUCT
HOUSING.
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AND
ENJOYS THE SUPPORT OF THE
CALIFORNIA NEWS PICK UP
PUBLISHERS ASSOCIATION AND THE
BEACH CITIES HELP DISTRICT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS AGUIAR-CURRY.
SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM.
COR CLUB THERE ALL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESERT OF
THOUGH ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE
DESIRE TO GO.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THOSE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF AN ICE FIFTY
KNOWS TWENTY ONE THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEMS EIGHTY FIVE
THROUGH EIGHTY SEVEN PASS AND
RETAIN.
WHERE FILE ITEM EIGHTY EIGHT AB
TWENTY FOUR OH TO BY MR LOW THE
CLERK WILL READ?
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR OH TO
BUY SOME REMEMBER LOW ACTUALLY
CANNABIS.
SURE LOW YOU MAIL BUT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
THIS IS A CONSUMER PROTECTION
BILL WITH RESPECT TO A DON'T USE
CANNABIS AND PROTECTS CONSUMERS.
ARE BY PROHIBITING LICENSEES
FROM SHARING PRIVATE INFORMATION
WITH THIRD PARTIES WITHOUT
CONSENT I RESPECTFULLY ASK DR
VOTE.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM. FOR CLUB. MEMBERS VOTE.
THIS OUT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
WELL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THOSE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF AN ICE FIFTY
EIGHT KNOWS FOR THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM EIGHTY NINE IS
AB.
TWENTY FOUR THIRTEEN BY MISTER
DAVID CHIU THE CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR
THIRTEEN BY SOME A MEMBER DAVID
CHIU AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE
TENANCY MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES AB TWENTY FOUR
THIRTEEN WOULD PROTECT TENANTS
FROM BEING EVICTED OR PENALIZE
SIMPLY FOR CALLING EMERGENCY
ASSISTANCE OR NINE ONE ONE.
UNDER CURRENT LAW ATTENDED COULD
BE DEEMED A NUISANCE IF HER
RENTAL IS A SITE OF A CERTAIN
NUMBER OF POLICE CALLS. WHICH
COULD BE THE GROUNDS FOR FICTION
THESE NUISANCE ORDINANCE IS
PLACE A VICTIM AND AN IMPOSSIBLE
DILEMMA.
INDIRA LIFE THREATENING
SITUATION TO KEEP ONE'S HOME OR
CALL FOR HELP AND RISK EVICTION.
THIS IMPACTS THOSE WHO HAVE
EXPERIENCED DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SEXUAL ASSAULT TRAFFICKING OR
ELDER ABUSE OR RIGHT TO A SAFE
HOME ACT WOULD EXPAND THE
CIRCUMSTANCES UNDER WHICH A
TENANT WHO CALLS EMERGENCY
ASSISTANCE IS PROTECTED. ALLOW
THIRD PARTY DOCUMENTATION TO
ESTABLISH EVICTION PROTECTIONS
AND PROVIDE A REBUTTABLE
PRESUMPTION IN EVICTION CASES.
AS WELL AS PREEMPT LOCAL
ORDINANCES THAT IMPOSE PENALTIES
FOR CALLING EMERGENCY ASSISTANCE
THIS BILLS HAD NO OPPOSITION AND
I APPRECIATE THE STRONG
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT OUT OF ALL
COMMITTEES. WITH ZERO KNOWN
VOTES AND WITH THAT RESPECT WE
ASK YOUR SUPPORT.
YOU KNOW RECESSION DEBATE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THIS DIRE VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLE ANTI ABOUT AYE SIXTY
EIGHT NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM NINETY PASS
RETAIN.
THAT BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER NINETY ONE AB TWENTY SIX
FORTY CORPORATE GREED.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIX FORTY
BY SOME REMEMBER WHAT AND
ACTUALLY TO FISH.
DOCTOR WOULD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS FOR DECADES
TRIBES ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS IN
THE FISHING COMMUNITY HAVE
WORKED WITH STAKEHOLDERS TO
REOPEN THE OVER FOUR HUNDRED
MILES OF FISH SPAWNING HABITAT
UPSTREAM OF THE KLAMATH DAMS. TO
NAMES FISH SPECIES
AND TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
CALIFORNIA OREGON IN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND PACIFICORP CAME
TO AN AGREEMENT TO SET PLANS IN
MOTION. TO MOVE FOR THE DAMAS
DAMS THAT CURRENTLY STAND ON THE
KLAMATH RIVER.
AB TWENTY SIX FORTY GIVES THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
THE OF THIRTY TWO AUTHORIZED.
TAKE THE TAKE OR POSSESSION OF
THE LOST RIVER SACRIFICIAL AND
THE SHORT NO SUCKER FISH
RESULTING FROM IMPACTS
ATTRIBUTABLE TO THE REMOVAL OF
THE KLAMATH DAMS.
THE BILL GIVES THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE THE TOOLS THEY
NEED TO PROTECT THESE TWO
ENDANGERED SPECIES. AND PROVIDE
LEGAL PROTECTIONS DURING THE
CLIMATE THEM A NEW REMOVE
REMOVAL PROCESS
THE BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULD SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
COR CLUB RUN. ON MEMBERS VOTE.
THESE ARE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE OF AN ICE
FIFTY TO KNOW SEVENTEEN THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEMS NINETY TWO NINETY
THREE AND NINETY FOUR PASS
RETAIN WORK FILE ITEM NINETY
FIVE. AB TWENTY NINE EIGHTY TWO.
COOPERATE ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
NINE EIGHTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GLORIA ACTUALLY
TRANSPORTATION MISTER GLORIA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT AB TWENTY NINE
EIGHTY TWO THIS BILL AS A NON
VOTING MEMBER TO THE NORTH
COUNTY TRANSIT DISTRICT BOARD OF
DIRECTORS.
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE WHEN IN
CT WAS CREATE THE AGENCY DID NOT
SERVE THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO
THERE IS NO NEED TO INCLUDE THAT
JURISDICTION ON SPORT. HOWEVER
TODAY IN CT DOES PROVIDE
SERVICES IN THE CITY OF SAN
DIEGO AND THE FREQUENCY OF THE
TRAINS AND BUSES IN THAT
COMMUNITY. REQUIRES ESTABLISH
CHANNEL OF COMMUNICATION BETWEEN
THE BOARD IN THAT JURISDICTION
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
IT WAS GLORIA SEE NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE.
QUIRK LOVE THE ROLE. ON MEMBERS.
THE SAD ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTE
THIS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE ANTI ABOUT AS FORTY
EIGHT KNOWS FIFTEEN.
THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM
NINETY SIX PASS RETAIN.
WHILE I NINETY SEVEN IS A B.
THIRTY EIGHTY EIGHT CORPORATION
ASSEMBLY WILL THIRTY EIGHTY
EIGHT PRICE ONLY AMBER KANSEN
CHU AND ACTUALLY THE HEALTH
FACILITIES.
MISTER CHIU YOU MAY OPEN.
SYNCHRONOUS FOR SPEAKER I RISE
TO PERCENT AB THIRTY EIGHTY
EIGHT.
A BILL BROUGHT TO MY ATTENTION
BY THE SENIOR LIVING IN THE
CONTINUING CARE RETIREMENT
COMMUNITY. DISPIRITO ARE ALL C.
C. R. C.'S TO STUDY FUTURE.
FINANCIAL RISK AND DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE COSTS IN THEIR
FACILITY TO BETTER PLAYING FOR
IMMINENT EXPENDITURE AND LIMIT
THE FINANCIAL IMPACT TO THEIR
RESIDENT.
THIS STUDY ONLY NEEDS TO BE DONE
EVERY FIVE YEARS THE REQUIREMENT
pCURRENT FINANCIAL DISCLOSURE
REQUIREMENT. THAT THE NEW WORKED
WHICH WOULD TAKE DEEPER INTO
FACTORS THAT COULD POSE
FINANCIAL RISK
SUCH OBSERVE A FAILING
INFRASTRUCTURE. A POPULATION
CHANGE AT THE FACILITY AND LONG
TERM AND SHORT TERM A MAJOR
EXPENSES TO AVOID FUTURE. RISK
THAT COULD RESULT IN INCREASING
OPERATION COST THEM A PUT
RESIDENTS IN DANGER FOR SHARP
MONTHLY FEET ERRED GREEN CREASES.
MOBILE PROTECT CONSUMERS AND
ALSO PROMOTE GOOD BUSINESS
PRACTICE I URGE FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS YOU.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM CORP LIBERAL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THESE ARE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE AND HOW THAT TIES
FIFTY FOUR NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
MEMBERS WERE FILE ITEM NINETY
EIGHT.
AB THIRTY ONE SIXTY COOPERATE
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY ONE SIXTY
BY SOME REMEMBER GRAYSON AND
ACTUALLY A PUBLIC LANDS.
MISTER GRAYSON.
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTY ONE SIXTY WILL
EXEMPT THE SALE OR LEASE OF
SPECIFIC FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
PROPERTIES.
FROM THE REQUIREMENT THAT THE
STATE LANDS COMMISSION IS GIVEN
THE FIRST RIGHT OF REFUSAL A
ROLE THAT WAS CREATED THREE SB
FIFTY LAST YEAR.
AB THIRTY ONE SIXTY PROVIDES
VERY LIMITED EXEMPTION FOR
FEDERAL MILITARY INSTALLATIONS
THAT ARE PARTICIPATING WITH
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN THE BASE
REALIGNMENT CLOSER OTHERWISE
KNOWN AS BRAK TRANSFER AND
REDEVELOPMENT PROGRAM. MY
DISTRICT IS HOME TO ONE OF THESE
FORMER BASIS THE CONCORD NAVAL
WEAPONS STATION.
THE CITY OF CONCORD IS THE LOCAL
REDUCE AUTHORITY FOR THIS FORMER
NAVAL BASE AS BEEN WORKING WITH
THE US NAVY FOR OVER THIRTEEN
YEARS ON THE BASIS TRANSFERRED
TO LOCAL CONTROL. A. B. THIRTY
ONE SIXTY WILL ENABLE THE CITY
OF CONCORD TO COMPLETE THE
FEDERAL TRANSFERPROCESS AS PART
OF THE CITY'S REUSE PROJECT.
THE BILL HAS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT IN POLICY AND FISCAL
COMMITTEES AND HAS NO OPPOSITION.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NIGHT.
THANK YOU MISS GRAYSON MISTER
KILEY YOUR RECOMMENDS.
WHAT WE HAVE HERE IS A PERFECT
EXAMPLE OF WHY IT'S A REALLY BAD
IDEA TO PASS LAWS THAT ARE
OBVIOUSLY UNCONSTITUTIONAL?
BECAUSE SUCH ALONG OR REALLY
LAWLESSNESS CAN WRECK HAVOC.
WHEN OUR STATE INTEL A COURT AS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO THROW IT OUT.
BUT THAT'S NOT MY ARGUMENT
THAT'S THE VERY ARGUMENT. BEHIND
THE BILL BEFORE US.
THAT A BILL WE PASSED JUST LAST
YEAR S. B. FIFTY IS NEGATIVELY
IMPACTING THE CONCORD REUSE
PROJECT IN FACT THE AUTHOR
STATEMENT FOR TODAY'S BILL SAYS
THIS IS JUST ONE OF NUMEROUS.
PROJECTS IN CALIFORNIA QUOTE
NEGATIVELY IMPACTED BY THIS NEW
STATE LAW S. B. FIFTY AND AS A
REFRESHER WHAT S. B. FIFTY DID.
WAS REALLY.
SOMETHING QUITE REMARKABLE.
IT SAID WHEN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS LOOKING TO
TRANSFER LAND EITHER TO ANOTHER
ENTITY OR A PRIVATE PARTY.
THEN I AS THERE'S OFTEN GOOD
REASON TO DO AS IN THE EXAMPLE
BROUGHT UP BY THE AUTHOR TODAY.
THEN WE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
CAN INTERPOSE OURSELVES WE CAN
SAY NO TO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
WE CAN CALL THE DEAL OFF AND THE
STATE CAN THEN GRABBED THE LAND
FOR ITSELF. OR EVEN IT IF IT
DOESN'T IT CAN'T ACCORDING TO
THE AUTHOR STEPHEN FOR TODAY'S
BILL IMPEDE THE TIMING. OF THE
TRANSFER.
NO EVEN WOULD S. B. FIFTY WAS
PASSED.
NO ONE SERIOUSLY THOUGHT THIS IS
SOMETHING WE CAN ACTUALLY DO.
UNDER THE US CONSTITUTION.
AND THAT'S IMPORTANT TODAY'S
BELL BECAUSE SB FIFTY IS IN FACT
CURRENTLY BEING CHALLENGED IN
COURT AND TODAY'S BILL WOULD
ELIMINATE A BASIS FOR STANDING
ON THE PART OF THE U. S.
GOVERNMENT.
BUT WHY DO I SAY THAT NO ONE AT
THE TIME S. B. FIFTY WAS PASSED
SERIOUSLY THOUGHT IT WAS
CONSTITUTIONAL.
WELL FOR ONE THE ASSEMBLY
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE'S OWN
ANALYSIS SAID THERE'S A STRONG
POSSIBILITY THAT FEDERAL COURTS
WOULD FIND OF THIS BILL WOULD
VIOLATE THE PROPERTY BECAUSE. OF
THE U. S. CONSTITUTION.
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS YOU KNOW
WHAT I WANT TO MOCK ARGUMENTS
MADE IN FAVOR OF THE IDEA THAT
THE BILL WAS CONSTITUTIONAL.
IN ADDITION IT TO VIOLATING THE
PROPERTY BECAUSE OF THE U. S.
CONSTITUTION I THE ISSUE OF
FEDERAL PREEMPTION HAS ALSO BEEN
RAISED BY THE ONGOING LITIGATION
WITH RESPECT TO WHICH AGAIN
TODAY'S BILL WOULD ELIMINATE. A
BASIS FOR STANDING.
THEN WE TALK ABOUT FEDERAL
PREEMPTION AUTHORITY ALONG WITH
SOME OBSCURE STATUTE OR
REGULATION.
BUT THE FEDERAL LAW THAT S. B.
FIFTY VIOLATES IS A LITTLE
DIFFERENT.
IT'S A LAW PASSED BY CONGRESS IN
EIGHTEEN FIFTY.
AND OF THAT DATE SOUNDS FAMILIAR
THE TITLE OF THAT FEDERAL LAW
WAS AN ACT THROUGH THE ADMISSION
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA INTO
THE UNION.
THE ACT PROVIDED THAT SAID STATE
OF CALIFORNIA IS ADMITTED INTO
THE UNION UPON THE EXPRESS
CONDITION THAT THE PEOPLE OF
SAID STATE THROUGH THEIR
LEGISLATURE OR OTHERWISE SHALL
NEVER INTERFERE WITH THE PRIMARY
DISPOSAL OF THE PUBLIC LANDS
WITHIN ITS LIMITS. AND SHALL
PASS NO LAW AND YOU KNOW ACT
WHEREBY THE TITLE OF THE UNITED
STATES TO AND RIGHT TO DISPOSE
OF THE SAME SHALL BE IMPAIRED.
AND QUESTION.
THAT'S RIGHT LAST YEAR THIS
LEGISLATURE.
PAST
A LAW THAT EXPRESSLY VIOLATES A
CONDITION OF CALIFORNIA'S
STATEHOOD.
ON TODAY'S MEASURE I'M URGING
MEMBERS TO WITHHOLD YOUR VOTE.
INTEL THE BILL HAS BEEN AMENDED
TO EXEMPT FROM THE
UNCONSTITUTIONAL S. B. FIFTY NOT
JUST ONE TYPE OF TRANSFER. BUT
ALL TRANSFERS
FOR EXAMPLE ONE PROJECT THAT'S
BEEN HAMSTRUNG BY THE BILL IS
THE RESULT VITAL IS ASIAN OF THE
VA IS THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY EIGHT
ACRE.
WEST LA CAMPUS
THAT PROJECT INVOLVES LEASING
PROPERTY TO PROVIDE PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING AND SERVICES
FOR LOCAL VETERANS AND ISSUING
AN EASEMENT TO LOS ANGELES IN
ORDER TO SUPPORT THE PLAN PURPLE
LINE METRO PROJECT.
NOW I WOULDN'T BE SURPRISED IF
AFTER THIS BILL WE START GETTING
OTHER BELLS ASKING FOR FURTHER
EXEMPTIONS FROM SD FIFTY FOUR
OTHER TYPES OF PROJECTS UNTIL S.
B. FIFTY IS FINALLY AND
INEVITABLY STRUCK DOWN BY THE
COURTS I THINK I'D BE A LOT
EASIER. AND WOULD SPARE A LOT OF
HARM TO A LOT OF PROJECTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE IF WE
SIMPLY AMENDED THIS BILL TO TAKE
SB FIFTY OFF THE BOOKS NOW AND I
HOPE THAT THE NEXT TIME WE'RE
TEMPTED TO PASS AN
UNCONSTITUTIONAL LAW. WE
REMEMBER THIS THAT THAT IS A
LOSE LOSE FOR EVERYONE INVOLVED.
MISTER STONE YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE BILL AND
HANDS MOST OF THAT WAS REALLY
ABOUT A PREVIOUS BILL YOU CAN
CRITICIZE THAT BILL ALL YOU WANT
I APPRECIATE.
OUR COLLEAGUE FROM CONCORD.
WORKING ON A PREVIOUS LAW WHICH
IS WHAT WE DO ON A REGULAR BASIS
FIND FLAWS AND MOVE IT FORWARD.
WHETHER YOU'RE FRUSTRATED WITH
WHAT HAPPENED WITH BILLS LAST
YEAR OR NOT.
THAT TIME HAS PASSED WHAT IS
BEFORE US IS A BILL THAT
ADDRESSES A VERY REAL ISSUE A
VERY SPECIFIC ISSUE. AND IF YOU
WANT TO THROW OUT THE BENEFIT
THAT IT DOES.
BECAUSE OF SOME OTHER DESIRE TO
AMEND THIS BILL I SUGGEST.
YOU CAN ALWAYS INTRODUCE YOUR
OWN BILLS THAT'S
OUR AUTHORITY HERE ON THE FLOOR.
THIS IS AN APPROPRIATE BILL THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT WE DO NEED TO
ADDRESS TO MOVE FORWARD AND I
ASK FOR YOUR I'VE.
THE IMAGE DOWN SEE NO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
MR GRACING YOU MAY CLOSE.
YES I DO WANNA THANK.
COMMENTS FROM MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SCOTTS VALLEY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND THEN ALSO JUST TO
REMIND AS WAS STATED IN THE
OPENING STATEMENT THAT THE BILL
HAS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. AND POLICY
IN FISCAL COMMITTEES AND HAS NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
WHEN I.
WITH THAT CLERK LOCAL ROLL-ON
MEMBERS OF THE.
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSE TO ROLL EYES FIFTY TWO
KNOWS ONE THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM NINETY NINE PASS
RETAIN THAT BRINGS US TO FILE
ITEM ONE HUNDRED. AB SEVENTEEN
SIXTY EIGHT CORPORATE ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVENTEEN SIXTY EIGHT BY
FAMILY MEMBERS STEINORTH AND
ACTUALLY THE HOUSING MISTER
STEINORTH. IF YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY EIGHT WILL
PROVIDE THE COUNTY OF SALMON
MEDINA WITH AN ADDITIONAL
MECHANISM TO DEVELOP OPERATE IN
FINANCE MIDDLE INCOME HOUSING
PROJECTS.
BY JOINING IN THE PILOT PROGRAM
WITH THE COUNTIES OF SAN DIEGO
AND SANTA CLARA ESTABLISHED LAST
YEAR BY AB SIXTEEN THIRTY SEVEN
GLORIA.
THIS WILL INCENTIVIZE DEVELOPERS
TO BUILD HOUSING PROJECTS TO
BOTH MIDDLE AND LOW INCOME
RESIDENTS IN THE COUNTY OF SAN
BERNARDINO WHICH ARE LARGELY
UNDERSERVED. OUR STATE POLICIES
OFTEN PREVENT LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS FROM CLIMBING THE
LADDER OUT OF POVERTY BECAUSE
THEY MAKE TOO MUCH MONEY TO
RECEIVE ASSISTANCE.
WE MUST TAKE IN ALL OF THE ABOVE
APPROACH TO TACKLE THE HOUSING
CRISIS IN CALIFORNIA MAKING SURE
THAT WE ADDRESS THE GROWING
MIDDLE MISSING MIDDLE THAT IS
OFTEN FORGOTTEN AND POLICY
DISCUSSIONS.
ALLOWING THE COUNTY TO PRODUCE
ADDITIONAL MIXED INCOME PROJECTS
GIVES THEM THE FLEXIBILITY TO
MAKE THE COST PENCIL OUT. BY
INCORPORATING MARKET RATE AND
MIDDLE INCOME HOUSING TO HELP
PAY FOR LOW INCOME AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. UNDER THIS PROPOSAL
EVERYONE IS GIVEN AN OPPORTUNITY
TO SUCCEED THIS LEGISLATION
ENJOYS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT HAS
HAD NO OPPOSITION. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THEY CAN BE STEINORTH.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CLERK LOCAL ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THIS OUT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
CLERK WILL. CLOSER ALL ANTI
ABOUT I SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS WERE
FILE ITEM ONE ON ONE AB
SEVENTEEN NINETY SIX THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTEEN NINETY SIX BY SOME
NUMBER MURATSUCHI AN ACTOR AND A
TENDENCY.
MISTER MURATSUCHI.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MEANT MISTER
SPEAKER. AB SEVENTEEN NINETY SIX
WILL ALLOW A TENANT IN A RENT
CONTROLLED DWELLING. TO INSTALL
AN ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
STATION IF THE TENANT IS WILLING
TO PAY FOR THE ENTIRE COST OF
INSTALLATION THIS BILL RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR EVER.
THANK YOU MISTER MERCY IF YOU
SEEN OUR DISCUSSION DEBATE.
COR CLUB THE WRONG. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE THAT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE.
TELL ME ABOUT I FIFTY KNOWS
THIRTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WERE FILE ITEM ONE OF
TWO AB TWENTY EIGHT.
FORTY SEVEN.
CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT FORTY
SEVEN BY FAMILY MEMBERS RUBIO
AND ACTUALLY TO REAL PROPERTY.
IS RUBIO.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER GOOD
AFTERNOON I RIGHT NOW TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT FORTY
SEVEN THIS BILL IS A TECHNICAL
MEASURE WITH CLEANS UP WHICH
CLEANS UP CODE SECTIONS.
RELEVANT TO THE COMMERCIAL AND
RESIDENTIAL TENANCY.
SOME SECTIONS OF THE CIVIL CODE
NUMBER COMMERCIAL AND
RESIDENTIAL REAL ESTATE TOGETHER
EVEN THOUGH THE UNDERLYING
INTENT OF THE LAW IS FOCUSED ON
INDIVIDUALS. INDIVIDUAL
RESIDENTIAL TENANTS AND NOT THE
COMPANIES IN THE BUSINESS TO
BUSINESS NATURE OF COMMERCIAL
REAL ESTATE.
OVER TIME AND WHERE IT MAKES
SENSE AN EFFORT IS BEING MADE TO
CLARIFY AND OR SEPARATE AREAS OF
THE LAW. WHERE IT DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE TO TREAT COMMERCIAL AND
RESIDENTIAL TRANSACTIONS IN THE
SAME MANNER?
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AND
PASSED OUT OF THE ASSEMBLY
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE ON CONSENT.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS RUBIO SENIOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CORPORAL OF.
MEMBERS OF.
IT IS OUT OF ON ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THOUGH.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DECIDED VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I SEVENTY
ONE.
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM ONE OF THREE PASS RETAIN
WE'VE DISPENSED WITH FILE ITEM
ONE OH FOUR ONE OH FIVE THIS
PAST RETAIN.
WE'VE DISPENSED WITH ONE OF SIX
MEMBERS WERE AT THE SENATE.
THIRD READING FILE.
FILE ITEM ONE OF SEVEN IS S. B.
SIX OH SIX CORPORATE.
SENATE BILL SIX OF SIX BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG AND ACTUALLY
TO WATER.
MISS RUBIO.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
SB SIX OH SIX.
LAST YEAR AFTER THE MOST OF YOUR
DROUGHT IN MIND MODERN HISTORY I
AND OTHERS IN THIS HOUSE BEGIN
THE PROCESS OF MAKING LONG TERM
WATER USE. IN CALIFORNIA VERSUS
MORE SUSTAINABLE.
THE BILL AND IT'S A COMPLETE UGH
PANNION AB SIXTEEN SIXTY EIGHT
AND SHIRTS OUR STATE WILL BE
MORE PREPARED TO HANDLE FUTURE
WATER SHORTAGES.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT HAS NEVER
BEEN DONE BEFORE. IT IS A
FRAMEWORK FOR DROUGHT RESILIENCY
IN THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY AND
FOR WATER USE EFFICIENCY.
A FRAMEWORK BUILT ON HUNDREDS OF
HOURS OF MEETINGS SIGNIFICANT
COMPROMISES AND FINDING COMMON
UNDERSTANDING.
IT IS FAIR TO WATER SUPPLIERS
AND EMPOWERS THE LEGISLATURE NOT
THE ADMINISTRATION.
FOR EXAMPLE THE BILL FOCUSES ON
THE EFFICIENT USE OF WATER
RATHER THAN CURTAILING WATER
RIGHTS
AND LOCAL DISTRICTS ARE IN
CONTROL ABOUT HOW. AND WHERE TO
FIND WATER SAVINGS NOT SOME
STATE AGENCY.
THE BILL HELPS COMMUNITIES TO
GROW BY ADJUSTING THEIR TARGETS
AS THEY ADD NEW RESIDENTS
BUSINESSES AND PARKS.
IT IS PROVIDED.
IT PROVIDES
FOR GRADUATE FORCE MEANT BY THE
STATE WATER BOARD AND STRICTLY
PROHIBITS THE STATE FROM
REQUIRING CIVIL PENALTIES ON
WATER USES.
THE BILL INCLUDES VARIANCES AND
ALLOWANCES FOR SPECIAL AND
UNIQUE CIRCUMSTANCES RATHER THAN
FORCING A ONE SIZE FITS ALL
APPROACH.
AND THERE IS A SIGNIFICANT BONUS
INCENTIVE FOR WATER DISTRICTS
THAT HAVE INVESTED IN ME
POSSIBLE REDUCE SYSTEM.
THE RESULT IS SOMETHING WE
SHOULD ALL BE PART OF.
GROUPS AS DIVERSE AS ORANGE
COUNTY WATER DISTRICT BUT I'M
NRDC AND PEPSI ALL SUPPORT THIS
LEGISLATION.
IT HAS BEEN A LONG AND
COMPLICATED PROCESS
BUT S. B. SIX A SIX AND A. B.
SIXTEEN SIXTY EIGHT WILL SET US
ON THE RIGHT PATH FORWARD.
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE ON SENATE BILL SIX
ALL SIX.
THANK YOU MS RUBIO MISTER ALAN
YOU'RE RECOGNIZE.
I RISE IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO
SB SIX OH SIX A LOOK AFTER THIS
LAST MOST RECENT AND SEVERE
DROUGHT. THE LAST THING WE
SHOULD BE DOING IS GIVING ANY
MORE POWER TO STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD. THE
BOTTOM LINE IS CALIFORNIANS SAY
MORE WATER THAN ANY OTHER STATE
WHERE THE MOST WATER CONSCIOUS
STATE IN THE NATION. YET WHEN WE
PASSED THIS WATER BOND SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS TWO POINT SEVEN
BILLION OF WHICH WAS SUPPOSED TO
GO TO NEW WATER STORAGE WHICH
ACTUALLY WOULD SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM.
NOT ONE PENNY OF THAT BOND MONEY
WAS SPENT.
AND NOW JUST RECENTLY IN
SACRAMENTO.
THE CALIFORNIA WATER COMMISSION
DENIED FUNDING NECESSARY.
TO FINANCE TEMPERANCE FLAT.
WHICH WOULD'VE BROUGHT WATER TO
THE ENTIRE CENTER CENTRAL VALLEY.
WE HAVE SITES RESERVOIR WE NEED
TO RAISE SHASTA DAM WE NEED TO
BUILD THOSE THE CARIS THERE'S
WATER PROJECTS UP AND DOWN THE
STATE THE STATE THAT THE STATE
WATER COMMISSION. DOES NOT WANT
TO BILL BECAUSE THEY SAY THEY DO
NOT PENCIL OUT THE LAST THING WE
NEED IS MORE WATER MANDATES IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WHAT WE
DO NEED IS TO COMPLETE THE
CALIFORNIA STATE WATER PROJECT
WE NEED TO BUILD NEW WATER
STORAGE UP AND DOWN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO THAT WHEN IT RAINS
WE ACTUALLY STORE OUR WATER? AND
DON'T ALLOW FIFTY PERCENT OR
MORE OF OUR WATER EVERY SINGLE
YEAR TO FLOW AND THE GOLDEN GATE
BRIDGE INTO THE PACIFIC OCEAN.
THIS BILL IS THE EXACT WRONG
APPROACH YET AGAIN BY SACRAMENTO
IT'S TELLING CALIFORNIA'S IT WE
LEAVE THAT WE LIVE IN A STATE OF
SCARCITY. WE DON'T LIVE IN A
STATE OF SCARCITY LAYS
ADJOURNMENT WE LIVE IN A STATE
OF ABUNDANCE
ALL WE NEED TO DO IS TO USE OUR
TEXT FOR OUR TECHNOLOGICAL
EXPERTISE. WE NEED TO BUILD NEW
WATER STORAGE UP AND DOWN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO WE CAN
STORE MORE WATER.
NOT FIGURE OUT WAYS
HOW TO TAKE WATER.
SOME CALIFORNIANS
IN EVER GREATER QUANTITIES WHICH
EXACTLY THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD WANTS TO
DO EXACTLY WHAT THIS BILL WANTS
TO DO EXACTLY WHAT THE BROWN
ADMINISTRATION IS ONE TO DO NOW.
GOING BACK DECADES WE'D TO BUILD
NEW WATER SOURCES OF CALIFORNIA
WE NEED FLOOD THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
WE'D ACTUALLY HAVE WATER STORAGE
OF CALIFORNIA'S GET GREEN LAWN
TO TAKE LONG SHOWERS THIS IS THE
EXACT WRONG APPROACH YET AGAIN
FROM SACRAMENTO I URGE A NO VOTE
ON THIS. LET'S BILL MORE WATER
STORAGE NOT IN POWER STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD
CALIFORNIA.
MISTER GALLAGHER YOUR RECOGNIZE.
YEAH
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS.
.
IT WAS A REALLY IMPORTANT PIECE
OF LEGISLATION EVERYBODY SHOULD
BE VERY FOCUSED ON BECAUSE IT'S
GONNA HAVE A DRAMATIC IMPACT.
ON EVERYBODY'S DISTRICT.
.
IT IS GOING TO IMPACT YOUR WATER
RATES IN YOUR DISTRICT.
IT'S GOING TO IMPACT HOW MUCH
CREDIT YOU GET FOR THE
INVESTMENTS THAT YOU'RE
COMMUNITIES HAVE MADE. AND
RECYCLING WATER AND OTHER
INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENTS FOR
EXAMPLE.
INTO ME.
WHAT'S SAD IS THAT YOU KNOW WE
STARTED THIS OUR.
WITH A COMPREHENSIVE PROCESS
WE'RE BRINGING LOTS OF
STAKEHOLDERS TOGETHER. IN THE
LEGISLATURE THIS IS GONNA BE A
LEGISLATIVE.
DRIVEN PROCESS.
AND THAT PROCESS LARGELY BROKE
DOWN.
WE HAD SOME GOOD DISCUSSIONS
BUT WE NEVER REALLY SAW. THE
AMENDMENT SAID A LOT OF US WERE
TALKING ABOUT.
NUMBER ONE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
SHOULD BE IN CONTROL THAT WE
SHOULD BE IN CONTROL TO MILLIE
OF HOW WE STEP HOW WE SET
STANDARDS THIS BILL STILL GIVES
THAT POWER.
ULTIMATELY TO THE WATER BOARD TO
MAKE THOSE DECISIONS.
ANOTHER THING IN THIS.
BILL DOESN'T DO AS IT DOESN'T
GET RID OF THE ONE SIZE FITS ALL
MODEL THIS STILL WOULD ALLOW
THEM TO THE STATE WATER BOARD TO
SET STANDARDS BASED ON THE WATER
BUDGET.
MODEL AND THERE'S LARGELY NOT A
LOT OF FLEXIBILITY AND TO USE
OTHER METHODS OF BITTER IT LOOK
EVERY EVERYBODY KNOWS SIT IN
THIS ROOM THAT WATER NEEDS ARE
DIFFERENT IN DIFFERENT PARTS OF
THE STATE.
SOME AREAS HAVE MADE LARGE SCALE
INVESTMENTS ARE RECYCLED WATER.
OTHERS OF US HAVE VERY STRONG
GROUND WATER TABLES AND AND WE
HAVE BACKUP WATER SUPPLIES THAT
PUT US IN A STRONGER POSITION.
SOME ARE REALLY FACING SOME
REAL DIRE STRAITS WITH REGARD TO
GROUND WATER.
AND THEN THEY NEED ADDITIONAL
WATER SUPPLIES.
IT'S DIFFERENT IN EVERY PART OF
THE STATE AND YET THIS BILL
DOESN'T TAKE THAT INTO ACCOUNT.
AND IT'S GONNA LARGELY GIVE ONE
AGENCY OR WHOLE LOT OF A POWER
TO SET.
AN ARBITRARY.
STANDARD FOR EVERYBODY AND THE
AND THE LEGISLATURE'S GONNA HAVE
VERY LITTLE ABILITY TO CHANGE
THAT.
SO WE SHOULD ALL BE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT.
RECYCLED WATER YES THERE IS IN
HERE AN INCENTIVE.
THAT ALLOWS FOR FIFTEEN PERCENT
FOR EXISTING FACILITIES.
AND TEN PERCENT FOR NEW
FACILITIES THAT SHOULD BE
CONCERNING FOR ABOUT IN HERE IF
WE REALLY BELIEVE.
IN EXPANDING MORE RECYCLED WATER
FACILITIES WIRE WE CREATED A
DISINCENTIVE.
YOU GET FIFTEEN IF YOU'VE GOT AN
EXISTING BUT IF YOU CREATE A NEW
ONE YOU GET LESS.
CREDIT.
TO ME THAT'S SORT OF BACKWARDS.
.
YOU'LL FINALLY I THINK THAT.
EVERYBODY SHOULD BE THINKING
ABOUT.
.
WHY OR WHY DO WE CONTINUE TO
GIVE OKAY OUR AUTHORITY AND THE
I THINK THAT'S REALLY THE BIG
THE BIGGEST THING HERE WHY DO WE
CONTINUE? THIS IS A BIG ISSUE WE
SHOULD BE DRIVING THAT PROCESS
IT'S OUR CONSTITUENTS
WHO ULTIMATELY GOING TO BE
IMPACTED.
BY A VERY BROAD REACHING POLICY.
IT SO WHAT I WOULD ASK IS THAT
WE ACTUALLY LET'S TAKE THIS BACK
TO THE DRAWING BOARD LET'S
CONTINUE TO WORK ON A THERE'S
BEEN A LOT OF PEOPLE. ON
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WHO HAD.
INFLUENCE ON IT BUT TO ME WHAT
THIS FEELS LIKE RIGHT NOW IS
THAT WE'RE REALLY AFRAID OF A
BUDGET TRAILER BILL COMING SO
WE'LL JUST TAKE WHATEVER WE CAN
GET.
AND MOVE FORWARD AND SOME ARE
HAPPY BECAUSE THEY GOT A FEW
THINGS THEY'RE ASKING FOR. BUT
LARGELY THIS IS STILL VERY
FLAWED. POLICY.
THAT YOU'RE QUITE DO YOUR
CONSTITUENTS WILL BE ASKING YOU
ABOUT A COUPLE YEARS WHEN YOU'RE
WATER RATES START GOING UP.
AND THEY'RE SAYING WHY IS THIS
HAPPENING IN WELL BECAUSE WE
HAPPEN TO COMPLY WITH S. B. SIX
A SIX.
AND WITH THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD WHO JUST
PASSED SOME VERY DRACONIAN
REGULATIONS ON
ALL OF US.
SO I REALLY ASK I WOULD REALLY
ASK YOU MAY NEED TO STAY OFF
THIS BILL OR VOTE NO. BECAUSE I
THINK WE CAN DO BETTER THANK YOU.
MS WALDRON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU.
I I RISE I'M BEHALF OF MY
FARMERS
IN MY LOCAL BUSINESSES WHO ARE
SOUTH OF THE GRAPEVINE SO GONNA
SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THOSE OF US
DOWN SOUTH FLORIDA'S. PAYS SOME
OF THE HIGHEST WATER RATES IN
THE STATE.
.
AND EVERYTHING DOWN THERE IS
BROWN SO WE CAN'T WATER ANYTHING
OUR LAWNS OF BROWN'S.
THE CITY OF ESCONDIDO THAT I
REPRESENT HAS THE TERTIARY
TREATED WATER. OF RECYCLING
PLANT BUT IT'S HAD NOW FOR OVER
TWENTY FIVE YEARS.
AND THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS
WHY I OPPOSE THIS BILL ALONG
WITH ALL OF MY LOCAL WATER
AGENCIES.
I THIS BILL IMPOSES A ONE SIZE
FITS ALL WATER USE STANDARD.
THAT DOES NOT ADEQUATELY ACCOUNT
FOR UNIQUE LOCAL CONDITIONS.
OR THE INVESTMENTS
AND THAT'S AN EXAMPLE INVESTMENT.
IN RELIABLE SUPPLY LIKE POTABLE
WE USE FOR RAW WATER RECYCLING.
THIS WILL UNDERMINE THOSE PAST
EVENTS INVESTMENTS AND SOURCES
OF SUPPLY AND UNDERCUT FUTURE
EFFORTS TO MAKE OUR COMMUNITY
WATER. MORE RESILIENT SECURE AS
WE HEARD.
FORMER COLLEAGUE IT DOES A
DISINCENTIVE TICKET EVEN LOOK AT
EXPANDING ON RECYCLED WATER
PROJECTS.
SO.
.
I OPPOSE THIS EXPANSIVE NEW
AUTHORITY AND VIRGIN THOUGH VOTE.
MR VALLEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
ALSO RISE IN IN OPPOSITION AND I
ALSO. LIKE TO SHARE THAT I WAS
PART OF THAT BIPARTISAN.
INITIAL GROUP IN THERE WERE
SEVERAL BILLS OUT THERE AND. I
WILL SAVE FROM A DISTRICT WHO
PRODUCES ABOUT.
SOME AROUND SIXTY FIVE PERCENT
OF THE STATE'S WATER.
THE FOLKS WHO ARE SOUTH TO ME
WHICH IS.
I GUESS FROM ABOUT WILLOWS I
WOULD SAY SOUTH IS SOUTH.
BUT YOU DONE A GREAT JOB OF
WATER CONSERVATION LEADING THE
WORLD IN WATER CONSERVATION
YOU'RE GONNA GET PENALIZED.
FOR BEING A GOOD STEWARD OF YOUR
WATER. IN THE FUTURE AND WE'RE
NOT IN A.
SPOT WHERE WE HAVE TO RIGHT NOW
MAKE THIS DECISION WHAT IS THE
URGENCY.
WERE ON IN A FULL BLOWN DROUGHT
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE TIME TO DO
THIS RIGHT TAKE THE POWER BACK
TO THIS HOUSE.
AND PUT UP POLICIES THAT WORK
FOR INDIVIDUAL AREAS OF THE
STATE.
SO I RECOMMEND A NO VOTE ON THIS
GIVE US SOME TIME THERE ARE A
LOT OF FOLKS WHO AREN'T HAPPY
WITH THIS. WITH THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION AND I WILL GUARANTEE
YOU IF YOU'RE. SOUTH OF
SACRAMENTO.
THIS WILL COME BACK TO HAUNT YOU
IS GOING TO DRIVE YOUR RATES UP
AND IT'S NOT GONNA INCREASE MORE
WATER.
SURE MATHIS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
MISTER SPEAKER COLLINS THE I'VE
GOTTA ECHO A LOT OF THESE
REMARKS YOU KNOW WATER IS
DIFFERENT WHETHER YOU'RE FROM
NOR CAL.
SO CAO THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY LA%
COACHELLA VALLEY SAN DIEGO. OR
THE EAST SIDE OVER AND OWNS
VALLEY.
MEMBERS I HELL FROM THE CITY OF
PORT OF VILLAGE A FEW YEARS AGO
WAS THE CITY WITHOUT WATER.
AND I'M ASKING YOU FOR NO VOTE.
SENATE BILL SIX A SIX FAILS TO
PROVIDE LOCAL MANAGEMENT AND
WATER PLANNING FLEXIBILITY.
WHICH IS EXTREMELY NEEDED.
S. B. SIX OR SIX PROPOSES A ONE
SIZE FITS ALL APPROACH THE FELLS
TO REFLECT THE DIFFERENT
CIRCUMSTANCES.
IN EACH COMMUNITY.
THERE WAS.
GRANDA LOCAL WATER SUPPLY
INVESTMENTS ARTIFICIALLY INFLATE
WATER RATES WITH OUT.
COMMENSURATE BENEFIT AND
NEGATIVELY AFFECT THE LOCAL
ECONOMY.
FOR URBAN WATER.
SUPPLIERS
WHERE'S MY LA CAUCUS.
WHICH HAD AMPLE SUPPLIES FOR.
THE DROUGHT ENIK SHE'D MANDATE
STATE.
CONSERVATION LEVELS THESE
REQUIREMENTS ARE UNNECESSARY.
ONE LESSON LEARNED.
FROM THIS PAST DROUGHT IS THAT
FLEXIBILITY IN IMPLEMENTING.
SHORTAGES. PLANS ALLOWED WATER
AGENCIES TO BE CREATIVE.
AND CALL UPON THAT OF I'VE
EARNERS WATER SUPPLIES THEY HAVE
TO DEVELOP.
AND PAID.
FOR TO WHETHER DROUGHT CYCLES.
THIS BILL LACKS WIDESPREAD
SUPPORT FROM LOCAL WATER
SUPPLIERS.
ACCORDING TO THE COALITION WATER.
AGENCIES LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
RELATED ASSOCIATIONS
QUOTE SENATE BILL SIX ALSO WORKS.
GRAND STATE AGENCIES EXPANSIVE
NEW ENFORCEMENT POWERS.
INCLUDING THE ABILITY TO REQUIRE
WATER SUPPLY TO TAKE PUNITIVE
ENFORCEMENT.
ACTIONS ON THEIR CUSTOMERS.
AND THE AUTHORITY TO DENY STATE
GRATTON LOAN FUNDS FOR FAILURE
TO ME.
AN UNDEFINED STANDARD OF
COMPLIANCE.
SENATE BILL SIX OH SIX IS
ENFORCEMENT.
PROVISIONS NEED TO BE SHIFTED
AWAY FROM PROVIDING YOU PUNITIVE
ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITIES TO THE
STATE AGENCY AND POURED
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE.
ANY INFORMATION SHARING ALONG
THE APPROPRIATE AUTHORITIES TO
ENSURE THAT REPORTING PLAN AND
OTHER REQUIREMENTS ARE SATISFIED.
CALIFORNIA'S CONTINUE TO
CONSERVE WATER.
CHANGES TWO BEHAVIORS FIXTURES
AND EQUIPMENT THAT ARE MADE.
FOR CONSERVATION PURPOSES DURING
THE DROUGHT HAVE GENERALLY BEEN
MAINTAINED.
ACCORDING TO THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD
THEMSELVES CALIFORNIA'S WATER
SAVING HER EACH.
EIGHT POINT FIVE PERCENT OCTOBER
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN.
COMPARED TO OCTOBER TWENTY
THIRTEEN PUDDLE WATER PRODUCTION.
FOR THE. THREE HUNDRED NINETY
SIX SUPPLIERS REPORTING. BASED
ON THE ESTIMATES THAT THE
AVERAGE PERSON USES POINT TWO
ACRE FEET OF WATER PER YEAR THIS
SAVINGS IS ENOUGH TO SUPPLY.
TWO THOUSAND.
FOR.
HE TWO OR TWO HUNDRED FORTY TWO
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS
WITH WATER.
FOR ONE YEAR.
FORTY ONE PERCENT OF SUPPLIERS
REPORTING AN OCTOBER TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN ACHIEVED WATER
SAVINGS.
BETWEEN TEN TO TWENTY PERCENT
COMPARED TO THE SAME MONTH IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN THE SUPPLIER
SERVE MORE THAN. TWELVE POINT
THREE MILLION PEOPLE TEN PERCENT
A SUPPLIER SERVING MORE THAN ONE
POINT THREE MILLION CALIFORNIA'S
REPORTED WATER SAVINGS. OF
TWENTY PERCENT OR MORE.
THIS CONTAINS PROBLEMATIC
LANGUAGE THAT MAY ALLOW THE
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD TO INCREASE ENVIRONMENTAL
FLOWS WITH OUT CALIFORNIAN
FIREMAN ó QUALITY ACTION
REVIEW. SENATE BILL SIX OH SIX
SPECIFIES AN ACTION OF THE BOARD
TAKEN UNDER THIS CHAPTER SHALL
BE DEEMED.
TO BE A CLASS EIGHT ACTION A
CLASS EIGHT EXEMPTION UNDER
SEQUEL CONSIST OF ACTIONS TAKEN
BY REGULATORY AGENCIES. TO
AUTHORIZED BY STATE OR LOCAL
ORDINANCE TO ASSURE. THE MAIN
ANSWER RESTORATION ENHANCEMENT
OR PROTECTION OF THE ENVIRONMENT
WHERE THE REGULATORY PROCESS
INVOLVES PROCEDURES. TO
PROTECTION OF THE ENVIRONMENT.
THIRTY SECONDS MR MATHIS.
MEMBERS I DON'T HAVE TIME TO
READ ALL MY PROBLEMS WITH THIS
AYE IT THIS BILL QUITE FRANKLY
ROOM RATE REMINDS ME OF OF
SOMETHING OUT OF.
IT A ANY ADVENTURES MOVIE WHERE
WHERE YOU WOULD HEAR THE.
ON THE DOOR IN AN AGENCY SAYING.
YOUR COMPLIANCE WILL BE REWARDED.
THIS ISN'T A HELL HYDRILLA.
THIS IS REAL LIFE
THIS IS PEOPLE'S LIVELIHOODS.
THE IDEA OF GIVING THE STATE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD
MORE POWER TO COME KNOCKING ON
YOUR DOOR.
TO SAY HEY GUESS WHAT YOUR
COMPLIANCE WILL BE REWARDED
CONSERVE MORE. CONSERVE MORE ONE
ASKING YOU. MY FELLOW COLLEAGUES
CONSERVE YOUR VOTE LAY OFF LET'S
GET THIS RIGHT.
FUTURE GENERATIONS DEPEND ON IT.
THIS FRIEDMAN.
YOUR ATTACKS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
I FIRST WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE AND
THANK ALL THE MEMBERS WHO HAVE
REYES THERE MIGHT CENTER
SPEAKING TODAY ON THIS ISSUE IT
IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT ISSUE.
IT'S AN ISSUE THAT MANY OF US
HAVE BEEN DISCUSSING IN TERMS OF
THIS BILL ITS COMPANION BILL AB
SIXTEEN SIXTY EIGHT FOUR YEAR
AND A HALF. ANOTHER BUILT ON
CONVERSATIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
HAPPENING UP HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE FOR MANY MANY YEARS.
THE LESSONS FROM THE LAST LAST
DROUGHT.
WE'RE VERY IMPORTANT WE SAW IN
THAT DROUGHT THAT THERE WERE
SOME WATER AGENCIES THAT WERE
VERY PREPARED TO DEAL WITH
DROUGHT IN THEIR OTHER WATER
AGENCIES THAT WERE NOT PREPARED
TO DEAL WITH DROUGHT. ONE THING
THAT WAS CONSISTENT ACROSS
CALIFORNIA WHERE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA SAYING.
WHY ARE WE NOT A MORE EFFICIENT
STATE?
WHY DO WE NOT HAVE?
ADEQUATE PREPARATIONS IN SO MANY
PARTS OF OUR STATE.
MY CONSTITUENTS THAT TO ME WHERE
VERY EFFICIENT USES OF WATER
WIRE WE NOW BEING TOLD THAT WE
HAVE TO REDUCE FIFTEEN PERCENT.
OR TEN PERCENT WELL WE ALREADY
ARE VERY LOW USERS OF WATER
WE'VE ALREADY PUT IN ALL OF THE
PLUMBING THAT WE CAN PUT IN.
WHAT THIS LEGISLATION DOES IS IT
MOVES THE STATE UP AWAY FROM
THOSE ONE SIZE FITS ALL TYPES OF
EMERGENCY DECLARATIONS THOSE
ARBITRARY PERCENT INTRODUCTIONS
THAT APPLY EQUALLY TO EVERYBODY
NO MATTER HOW EFFICIENT YOU ARE?
AND INSTEAD OF SETTING UP A ONE
SIZE FITS ALL TYPE OF PROCESS IT
LOOKS OUT LOCAL CONDITIONS AND
ALLOWS FOR THOSE CONDITIONS TO
HELP DICTATE HOW THOSE DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES BECOME EFFICIENT.
IT ALLOWS FOR A PROCESS WHERE
THE WATER AGENCIES THEMSELVES
COME UP WITH THE BREAST TYPE OF
DROUGHT MANAGEMENT PLANS THEY
CAMPER THEIR CONDITIONS WITH OF
COURSE NOW SOME MORE GUIDANCE
AND APPROVAL FROM THE STATE'S A
THAT THEY'RE NOT CAUGHT. EMPTY
HANDED ANY LONGER.
THIS HAS BEEN A LONG PROCESS
WITH A LOT OF COMPROMISES
BELIEVE ME I'VE I HAVE GRAY
HAIRS. FROM THESE BILLS FOR THE
LAST YEAR AND A HALF BUT THEY
COME TO A REALLY GOOD PLACE HOW
GOOD OF A PLACE IF THEY COME TO
WE HAVE A. A LOT OF THE FORMER
OPPONENTS OF THESE BILLS WHO ARE
NOW SUPPORTERS VERY LARGE WATER
AGENCIES UP AND DOWN THE STATE
EAST BAY MUD METROPOLITAN WATER
DISTRICT STE SFPUC IRVINE RANCH.
ORANGE COUNTY WATER DISTRICT.
CALIFORNIA WATER ASSOCIATION.
IT'S A SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP
GROUP CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL
UTILITIES ASSOCIATION WESTERN
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT THE
LIST GOES ON AND ON.
OF GROUPS WHO WOULD WHO WOULD
OPPOSE THIS BILL A YEAR AND A
HALF AGO WHO NOW SUPPORT AND
THAT'S IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT
SHOWS. THE AMOUNT OF COMPROMISE
AND THE AMOUNT OF TALKING THAT
WENT INTO THIS LEGISLATION.
WE CAN CONTINUE TO TALK AND TALK
AND TALK AS WE GO FURTHER AND
FURTHER INTO DROUGHT BUT IT'S
TIMEFOR US TO ACT AND TO DO
SOMETHING.
IS THIS GOING TO BE MAYBE THE
PERFECT BILL FOR EVERY SINGLE
ONE OF YOU I WOULD SAY YOU'RE
NEVER GOING TO CRAFT A BILL THAT
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF YOU IS GONNA
THINK IS ALWAYS A HUNDRED
PERCENT WONDERFUL. BUT I CAN
TELL YOU THAT WE HAVE GONE FAR
WITH THIS LEGISLATION WE HAVE
BROUGHT PEOPLE WHO WERE WHO WERE
OPPONENTS TO NOW BE SUPPORTERS.
THIS IS IMPORTANT LEGISLATION
THIS TAKES US NOW ON THE ROAD TO
STATEWIDE WATER EFFICIENCY AND I
WOULD URGE ALL OF YOU TO VOTE I
TODAY. AND ALLOW THIS IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION TO MOVE FORWARD
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
THANK YOU MISS FRIEDMAN MISTER
EDUARDO GARCIA HERE ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES I DON'T
KNOW WHAT MORE I COULD ADD TO.
THAT ARE CALLING HASN'T ALREADY
HIGHLIGHTED THE FACT IS THAT WE
HAVE UNDERGONE A. TREMENDOUS.
RIGOROUS.
AT SOMETIMES PAINFUL PROCESS OF
NEGOTIATING WHAT'S ULTIMATELY
BEFORE US TODAY.
AND THE IT'S BEEN WHAT I WOULD
CALL A PRETTY INCLUSIVE PROCESS
TO SAY THE LEAST.
A MANY.
INDIVIDUALS FROM.
THIS BODY.
PARTICIPATED IN THE
CONVERSATIONS.
TO ULTIMATELY.
SEE THE PUBLIC POLICY THAT'S
BEFORE US TODAY. A WE HAVE COME
QUITE A BIT OF WAYS AS MY
COLLEAGUES IN THE PREVIOUS
SPEAKER HAS MENTIONED.
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF EFFORT BY A
NUMBER OF WATER AGENCIES SMALL
LARGE OF FROM UP AND DOWN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT IF
SHIFTED THEIR POSITION. FROM MAY
ADAM IN NO POSITION
TWO NOW SUPPORTING.
THIS POLICY
I RESPECTFULLY ASK I ON THESE.
POLICIES THAT ARE BEFORE US IS
TAKING A LOT OF TIME AND WORK A
TO COME BEFORE US LET ME JUST GO
OVER A COUPLE OF THINGS. THAT
ARE IN THIS BILL.
INDOOR USE WERE ESTABLISHING
WATER BUDGETS MADE UP RENDERS
INDOOR USE OUTRIGHT USE
INCLUDING INDUSTRY WHERE
POSSIBLE.
WATER LOSS PART ABORT REUSE
WATER EXPANDS.
THE BUDGET ENFORCEMENT PROCESS
THAT DOES NOT ALLOW FOR WATER
RIGHTS TO BE IMPACTED REQUIRED
FORSMAN ON WATER SUPPLIERS
CUSTOMERS.
CHANGES AGRICULTURE WATER
MANAGEMENT PLANS URBAN DROUGHT
PLANNING AND RESPONSE AND
ESTABLISHES ROLE DRAW PLANNING.
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES SINCE THE
END OF LAST YEAR THE
CONVERSATIONS WHERE WE LEFT OFF
WATER SUPPLIERS WITH EXISTING
FACILITIES CAN NOW RECEIVE A
FIFTEEN PERCENT PROBABLE REUSE.
SOMETHING THAT WAS VERY
CONTENTIOUS
ARE ALONG THE WAY. CLARIFIES
THAT THERE WILL BE APPROVED
VARIANCES PROHIBITS THE WATER
BOARD FROM REQUIRING WATER
SUPPLIERS TO ISSUE FINES ON
THEIR CUSTOMERS.
SPECIFIES WHAT GOES INTO INDOOR
WATER USE COMPONENT AND ALLOWS
WATER SUPPLIERS.
TO CHECK THE WORK THAT WENT INTO
ESTABLISHING THE OUTDOOR
COMPONENT THOSE ARE A LOT OF
THINGS THAT MANY OF YOU BROUGHT
TO OUR ATTENTION AT THE END OF.
LAST SESSION THAT YOU WANTED TO
SEE REFLECTED IN THESE POLICIES.
SO TODAY THAT'S BEFORE YOU.
AND AS I MENTIONED THERE WAS A
LOT OF DELIBERATION AND
COMPROMISED THAT'S TAKEN PLACE A
TO GET TO THIS POINT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. IN APPRECIATE THE
LEADERSHIP MY COLLEAGUE FROM THE
GLENDALE AREA AS WELL AS FROM
THE.
.
I BELIEVE IT'S THE.
WELL WHEN PARK AREA THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
EXPECTED.
ALL DEBATE HAVING CEASED.
IT'S RUBIO WE MAKE LOS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THERE
IS A QUOTE IN THE WATER INDUSTRY
THAT SAYS
WITH USE FOR DRINKING WATERS
FOR FIGHTING WELL I WOULD NOT.
.
TELL YOU WHAT WE'VE BEEN DOING
FOR THE LAST YEAR AND A HALF.
BUT THE.
PART OF THE COMPROMISE IS REALLY
REALLY IMPORTANT.
WHEN I GOT HERE PART OF THE.
WORD COMPROMISE TO ME MEANT
THAT NOT EVERYBODY GOT
EVERYTHING AND BUT WE ALL GOT
SOMETHING AND I THINK IT TOOK A
YEAR AND A HALF FOR ALL OF US TO
BE AT THIS POINT.
IT TOOK A LOT OF.
GIVING INTO THINGS THAT WE NEED
MORE WEREN'T ABSOLUTELY.
HAPPY WITH BUT I THINK THAT
THIS IS A GOOD POINT I'M AND I
JUST WANT TO REMIND MY
COLLEAGUES THAT IF THERE IS
ANOTHER DROUGHT WE WON'T HAVE
ANY SAY SO THE GOVERNOR CAN
ALWAYS.
IMPOSE AN EMERGENCY AND HE OR
SHE HAS CONTROL OF WHATEVER.
STANDARDS THEY SAID AND SO
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
VOTE AND I HEAR MY COLLEAGUES.
FROM THE OTHER SIDE OF THE
AISLE AND I APPRECIATE THE
EMPLOYED AND I THINK THAT WE ARE
COMMITTED TO AT LEAST.
TO KEEP THE CONVERSATION GOING
I KNOW IT'S NOT PERFECT BUT I
COMMIT TO WORKING WITH YOU ON
FUTURE WATER LEGISLATION I HOPE
TO BE.
AND STAY IN THE WATER COMMITTEE
FOR FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS AND
AGAIN I COMMIT TO WORKING WITH
ALL OF YOU TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
WATER LEGISLATION THAT'S PASSED.
IS NOT.
.
IT MAY NOT FIT EVERYBODY BUT AT
LEAST WE ALL HAVE A SEIZE ON
WHAT IT IS A WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR BY
BOAT.
WITH THAT CLERK LOCAL ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE.
IS OUT OF ON ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THOSE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE YOUR OWN TYPE OF AN ICE
FORTY SIX KNOWS TWENTY SIX.
THAT MEASURE PASSES WERE FILE
ITEM ONE A WAIT AND SEE ARE ONE
TWENTY TWO CORKERY.
THANK A RESOLUTION ONE TWENTY
TWO BY SENATOR WHEN RELATIVE TO
CALIFORNIA SERVING DAY.
MISTER HARPER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
TODAY I RISE TO INTRODUCE SCR
ONE TWENTY TWO WHICH RECOGNIZES
SEPTEMBER TWENTIETH AS
CALIFORNIA SURFING DAY. THIS
SPECIAL DAY WILL BRING TOGETHER
THOUSANDS OF FROM OF OCEAN AND
BEACH LOVING FOLKS
SURFERS AND MILLIONS OF VISITORS
TO TRAVEL TO CALIFORNIA. TO
EXPERIENCE SURFING AND ITS
CULTURE.
OUR COASTAL CITIES POST NO MORE
SURFING EVENTS AND TOURNAMENTS
AS WAS ALLUDED TO EARLIER.
SURFING WAS INTRODUCED TO THE
MAINLAND AMERICAIN EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY FIVE BY THREE TEENAGE Y.
AND PRINCES. WHO WERE TAKING
BACK A IN TAKING A BREAK FROM
THEIR BOARDING SCHOOL AND SERVED
THE MOUTH THE SAN LORENZO RIVER
IN SANTA CRUZ? OVER A CENTURY
AGO HAWAIIAN SURFER NAMED GEORGE
FREETH BROUGHT SURFING TO
CALIFORNIA TO DEMONSTRATE
SURFBOARD RIDING AS A PUBLICITY
STUNT TO PROMOTE THE OPENING OF
THE RAILROAD OWNED BY HENRY
HUNTINGTON. WHO GAVE THE NAME TO
HUNTINGTON BEACH?
FREE SIR THE HUNTINGTON BEACH
PIER IN TRAVELED UP AND DOWN THE
COAST DEMONSTRATING SURFING AND
LIFEGUARDS SKILLS.
SERVING HAS BECOME AN IMPORTANT
PART OF CALIFORNIA'S CULTURE AND
IMAGE AND HAS GROWN INTO AN
INTERNATIONAL SPORT. IN FACT OF
ONE OF THE FOLKS WHO I ATTENDED
HUNTINGTON BEACH HIGH SCHOOL
WITH KELLY SLATER IS THE FELLOW
WHO IS BRINGING SURFING TO THE
INLAND AYE CENTRAL VALLEY IN THE
MORE.
BUT FOR THE FIRST TIME IN ITS
HISTORY.
SURFING WILL MAKE ITS DEBUT AS
AN OLYMPIC SPORT IN TWENTY
TWENTY SUMMER OLYMPIC GAMES IN
TOKYO THE OLYMPIC GAMES WILL BE
A FANTASTIC OPPORTUNITY TO
INCLUDE ENCOURAGE OCEAN
AWARENESS AND SUPPORTING OUR
FUTURE YOUNG SURFERS. AND I URGE
THE FOLKS A TO SUPPORT SURFING
THROUGH THE LYMPICS IN LOS
ANGELES AYE IN CALIFORNIA IN
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT. SCR ONE
TWENTY TWO WILL NOT ONLY
RECOGNIZE SEPTEMBER TWENTIETH
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AS CALIFORNIA
SURFING DAY BUT ALL COMMEND ALL
THOSE WHO HONOR THE HISTORY.
CULTURE AND FUTURE OF SURFING I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
AND THAT THE FIRST RULE BE OPEN
FOR CO AUTHORS.
THANK YOU MISTER HARPER.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
BAY ON THE RESOLUTION MISTER
HARPER'S ASSET THE FIRST ROLE BE
OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS ON SCR. ONE
TWENTY TO CARPOOL OF THE ROLL-ON
CISCO AUTHORS.
CO AUTHORS ON THE SENATE
RESOLUTION.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE THERE SIXTY SIX
CO AUTHORS OUT AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NO.
YES HAVE THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE ARE CONSENT CALENDAR.
DOES ANY MEMBER WHICH REMOVE AN
ITEM FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR
SEEING HEARING NINE.
THE CORPORAL READ THE SECOND DAY
CONSENT CALENDAR. ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTY TO SIXTY ONE BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS AND ACTUALLY THE
CANNABIS.
CLERK LIBERAL.
ALL MEMBERS HER DESIRE TO VOTE
THIS IS CONSENT.
CALENDAR MEMBERS THIS IS CONSENT
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I SEVENTY
FIVE NO ZERO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ADOPTED IN THE CLERK
WILL READ.
REMAINING ITEMS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
NINES WHILE I SEVEN FIVE NO ZERO
AND ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY TO
FORTY SEVEN I SEVENTY FIVE NO
ZERO.
MEMBERS I WOULD ASK THAT YOU
TAKE YOUR SEATS WE ARE GOING TO
BE A TURNING. IN THE MEMORY FOR
A FORMER GOVERNOR OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. AS WELL AS A
FORMER MEMBER OF THE LEGISLATURE
I WOULD ASK THAT YOU.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS AND GIVE
YOUR RESPECTFUL ATTENTION DEAR
COLLEAGUES WILL BE ADJOURNING IN
THE MEMORY.
MISTER. O'DONNELL FOR YOUR
ADJOURNMENTS. IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO ADJOURN
IN THE MEMORY OF OUR FORMER
GOVERNOR. GEORGE DEUKMEJIAN.
WHO HAS BEEN CONSIDERED ONE OF
THE MOST RESPECTED LEADERS
IN CALIFORNIA POLITICS?
GEORGE DEUKMEJIAN WAS BORN ON
JUNE SIXTH NINETEEN TWENTY EIGHT
OUTSIDE OF ALBANY NEW YORK.
HE WAS THE SON OF ARMENIAN
IMMIGRANTS AND WAS TREMENDOUSLY
PROUD. OF HIS HERITAGE.
HE GRADUATED FROM SIENA COLLEGE
IN NINETEEN FORTY NINE WITH A
DEGREE IN SOCIOLOGY AND THEN
WORKED HIS WAY THROUGH ST JOHN'S
UNIVERSITY EARNING HIS LAW
DEGREE. IN NINETEEN FIFTY TWO.
AFTER SERVING IN THE ARMY FOR
TWO YEARS HE MADE HIS WAY TO
CALIFORNIA.
WHERE HE WAS APPOINTED?
DODD DEPUTY COUNSEL FOR LOS
ANGELES COUNTY.
HE EVENTUALLY SETTLED IN LONG
BEACH WHERE HE BECAME INVOLVED
IN A HOST OF CIVIC ACTIVITIES
INCLUDING THE LIONS CLUB.
A COMMUNITY CHESS THE RED CROSS
THE BOY SCOUTS
AND THE ELKS.
HE WAS EVEN NAMED LONG BEACH'S
MAN OF THE YEAR IN NINETEEN
FIFTY NINE.
GOVERNOR DEUKMEJIAN WENT ON TO
DEVOTE NEARLY THREE DECADES OF
HIS LIFE TO PUBLIC SERVICE.
SERVING AS A CALIFORNIA
ASSEMBLYMAN SENATOR STATE
ATTORNEY GENERAL. AND FINALLY
GOVERNOR.
FIRST AND FOREMOST GEORGE
DEUKMEJIAN SHOULD BE REMEMBERED
AS A FAMILY MAN.
HIS WIFE GLORIA SURVIVES HIM AND
SHOULD BE THANK HER SERVICE TO
THE STATE AS WELL.
I CAME TO KNOW GOVERNOR
DEUKMEJIAN AS A CITY COUNCILMAN
IN LONG BEACH AND HE WAS ALWAYS
WITH HIS WIFE OR ONE OF HIS
GRANDCHILDREN. IN TOW.
PROBABLY THE OFFICIAL PRO ART
PORTRAIT.
OF GOVERNOR DID DEUKMEJIAN WHICH
HANGS IN THE CAPITAL TELLS HIS
STORY BEST.
THE WEDDING RING ON HIS LEFT
HAND HIS OVERSIZED REPRESENTING
HIS LOVE AND DEVOTION TO HIS
WIFE AND FAMILY.
GOVERNOR DUKMAJIAN SHOULD ALSO
BE REMEMBERED AS A TRUE
GENTLEMAN.
HE WAS ALWAYS POLITE AND A CLASS
ACT.
THE MAN DID NOT HAVE AN ARROGANT
BONE IN HIS BODY.
HE HAD TO CALM DEMEANOR THAT
CARRIED RESPECT.
HE WAS MODEST AS WELL HE STILL
LIVE IN THE HOUSE IN WHICH HE
RAISED HIS KIDS AND WAS HIS HOME
PRIOR TO BEING THE CALIFORNIA
GOVERNOR.
GOVERNOR DEUKMEJIAN IS POLICY
ACCOMPLISHMENTS WERE MANY.
HE WAS AN ARDENT FISCAL
CONSERVATIVE CONSERVATIVE AND
KNEW THAT A GOVERNOR AND
LEGISLATURE LIVES AND DIES BY
ITS BUDGET.
HE KNEW THAT EVERY DAY WE WERE
NOT IN A RECESSION WAS A DAY
CLOSER TO BEING IN A RECESSION.
SOMETHING WE CAN LEARN FROM.
HE WAS NOT AFRAID TO REACH
ACROSS THE AISLE AS WELL.
HE SIGNED LEGISLATION BANNING
ASSAULT WEAPONS.
GOVERNOR DEUKMEJIAN COULD BE
REASONABLE.
AFTER HE LEFT THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE IN NINETEEN NINETY ONE.
GOVERNOR DEUKMEJIAN LARGELY
RETREATED FROM POLITICAL LIFE TO
FOCUS ON WHAT WAS MORE IMPORTANT
TO HIM THAN ANY LAW HE'S.
GOVERNOR DEUKMEJIAN IS SURVIVED
BY HIS LOVING WIFE OF SIXTY ONE
YEARS GLORIA. THEIR CHILDREN
LESLIE GEORGIAN ANDREA AND A SIX
GRANDCHILDREN.
I ASK THAT WE ADJOURNMENT MEMORY
OF AN ACCOMPLISHED. GOVERNOR AN
ACCOMPLISHED FAILURE AND
GOVERNOR GEORGE DEUKMEJIAN.
SPEAKER.
THANK YOU MISTER O'DONNELL
MISTER HARPER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IF SOMEONE WHO IS A BORN IN LONG
BEACH.
NGUYEN AND GEORGE DEUKMEJIAN
WITH THE STATE SENATOR
REPRESENTING THE AREA. I JOIN.
WITH THE MEMBER FROM LONG BEACH
I RECOGNIZING THIS A TRUE
STATEMENT
A GENTLEMAN. AND A GREAT
REPRESENTATIVE FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND I ASK HIM I ENJOY
HIM IN ADJOURNING THE MEMORY FOR
GEORGE TO COMMISSION.
MISTER COOLEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
COLLEAGUES EMPLOYERS TO RISE
TODAY IN HONOR OF GOVERNOR
GEORGE DEUKMEJIAN.
FOR THOSE MEMBERS OF MY CLASS
ELECTED IN TWENTY TWELVE.
HE HAD PRECEDED OUR CLASS IN THE
ASSEMBLY BY FIFTY YEARS
HE WAS RISEN ELECTED IN NINETEEN
SIXTY TWO.
PRECEDED WILLIE BROWN BY TWO
YEARS
WELL IT INCOME TELL SIX
FOR.
.
WHEN I THINK OF HIM AS GOVERNOR
I JUST TAKE OF HIS HE IS
RENOWNED AS A FISCAL
CONSERVATIVE WAS THAT.
BUT IT WAS ALSO A PROBLEM
SOLVING GOVERNOR.
AND OPEN TO ADDRESSING PROBLEMS
AS A ROSE.
.
DURING HIS TENURE CALIFORNIA
OPENED INTERSTATE FIVE.
DRAMATICALLY OPENED THE NUMBER
OF MILES OF ROADWAYS IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE PEOPLE RELYING UPON TO
TRAVEL ABOUT THIS GREAT STATE
DAY AND NIGHT.
.
HE A IMPLEMENTED A TWELVE
HUNDRED PERSON INCREASE
IN THIS STAFFING OF THE
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL.
DURING HIS TENURE.
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
RESOURCES ONE OUR ROADS TO MEET
THE NEEDS OF CALIFORNIANS.
SO COMMITTED FINANCIAL
CONSERVATIVE BUT NONE THE LESS.
EXERCISING THE POWERS HAVE HIS
OFFICE TO WATCH OVER THE STATE
AND TAKE NOTE OF CHANGING
CIRCUMSTANCES.
ARMONK I'M SURE WHEN DECEMBER.
NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT A ROSE HE
WAS THINKING ABOUT HIS STATE OF
THE STATE ADDRESS.
THAT HE WOULD MAKE IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY NINE.
AND ON DECEMBER SEVENTH OF
NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT.
A DEVASTATING EARTHQUAKE HIT
THIRD NATION OF ARMENIA.
AND ALMOST FIFTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
DIED.
AND COME JANUARY OF NINETEEN
EIGHTY NINE THE GOVERNOR LOOKING
THE CALIFORNIA LOOK IN OUR EARTH
QUAKE PAYROLLS.
AND INJECTED THE IDEA THAT WE
SHOULD DO SOMETHING SIGNIFICANT
TO DO WITH THE EARTH.
APPAREL OF EARTHQUAKE.
SO YOU SORT OF SEE HIS.
PERSONAL HERITAGE.
AFFECTED HIS SINCE ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT. FACE US IN THIS
GREAT STATE. AND INITIATE AND
LEADERSHIP ON THAT FRONT.
HE WAS AT FISCAL CONSERVATIVE
MISSILE DURING THE NINETEEN
EIGHTIES THERE'S LEAVES ONE TIME
DURING A PROTRACTED. BUDGET
IMPASSE.
IN WHICH LAWMAKERS WANTED IT GO
ISSUE A NOTICE OF EVICTION.
THE GOVERNOR WHO IS.
TEN ON THE FIRST FLOOR OF THIS
BUILDING.
S. BECAUSE THEY WERE FRUSTRATED
OVER WHERE THE BUDGET WAS GOING.
AND OF COURSE HE STOOD HIS
GROUND.
.
IT'S JUST ON A RISE I I'M NOT
FROM LONG BEACH.
BUT.
DURING MY TENURE HERE I HAD THE
PLEASURE ONE NIGHT.
OF SEEN.
GOVERNOR DEUKMEJIAN HIS WIFE
GLORIA ENJOYINGA QUIET EVENING
TOGETHER IN GOLD RIVER. AT THIS
INFIDEL GRILL.
AND I HAD THE OCCASION TO VISIT
WITH HIM A LITTLE BIT. AND.
.
EXTEND MY WELL WISHES AS AN
ASSEMBLYMEMBER.
AND SHARING THIS STORY THIS SO
OFTEN THE PICTURES OF HIS CLASS
OF SIXTY TWO WE'VE OFTEN USED IN
OUR GROUP PREVENTS.
THE CLASS OF TWENTY TWELVE.
CHOOSE OF GOVERNOR DEUKMEJIAN IS
COHORTS
WE GOT WAS A VERY VERY LARGE
CLASS INSTITUTION THE WAS A PART
OF IT SO.
ANYWAY AN HONOR TO RISE TODAY
AT HIS MEMORY.
MR IN THIS AREA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
I STAND IN HONOR OF A GREAT
CALIFORNIAN AND A GREAT ARMENIAN
AMERICAN GOVERNOR GEORGE
DEUKMEJIAN.
EQUATION WAS A DEDICATED AN
EXCEPTIONAL PUBLIC SERVANT
COMMITTED TO PROTECTING.
THE PUBLIC SAFETY.
I VALUED HIS PASSION FOR THE
RULE OF LAW. AND THE HE WAS
PROFOUNDLY SHAPED BY THE
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE AND THAT'S WHY
YOU COULD SEE HIS APPEARANCE.
TO THE RULE OF LAW.
HIS AUNT WAS KILLED BY OTTOMAN
TURKS IN THE GENOCIDE AND HIS.
PARENTS FLED FOR AMERICA.
.
ALL ARMENIANS FROM A YOUNG AGE
ARE TAUGHT ABOUT THE GENOCIDE.
AND THERE WE ARE TAUGHT NOT ONLY
TO REMEMBER BUT TO MAKE THE
WORLD A BETTER PLACE. BECAUSE OF
OUR ANCESTORS EXPERIENCE.
GOVERNOR DEUKMEJIAN INTERNALIZE
THESE LESSONS.
ONE OF HIS MOST SURPRISING MOVES
WITH HIS EVENTUAL SUPPORT OF THE
DIVESTMENT OF THE. UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA BOARD OF REGENTS
TEACHER AN EMPLOYEE RETIREMENT
FUNDS.
FROM FIRMS THAT DID BUSINESS IN
SOUTH AFRICA.
UPON HEARING NEWS OF THE SOUTH
AFRICA THAT SOUTH AFRICA WAS
HUNTING DOWN AND JAILING ANTI
APARTHEID ACTIVISTS
HE RALLIED HIS OWN APPOINTEES TO
SUPPORT DIVESTMENT.
GOVERNOR DEUKMEJIAN. WOULD NOT
USE CALIFORNIA'S MASSIVE
RETIREMENT FUNDS TO SUPPORT AN
UNJUST REGIME.
WHETHER YOU AGREED OR DISAGREED
WITH HIM ON POLICY ISSUES.
BY ALL ACCOUNTS HE WAS AN HONEST
PASSIONATE PERSON.
SERVED WITH GREAT INTEGRITY.
A PRAGMATIST AS WAS MENTIONED
BEFORE. THE GOVERNOR ASSIGNED AN
ASSAULT WEAPONS
BAN AFTER A MASS SHOOTING.
WE SHOULD REMEMBER HIM AS
SOMEONE WILLING TO PLACE COULD
POLICY AHEAD OF IDEOLOGY. AND
THE GOVERNOR WILLING TO WORK
ACROSS PARTY LINES.
AS IN ARMENIAN. THE WAS A ROLE
MODEL. FOR THE COMMUNITY A
COMMUNITY LEFT WITH A MISTRUST
OF GOVERNMENT FROM THE GENOCIDE.
OF TWO LIVES UNDER COMMUNISM AND
TO THE DIASPORA EXPERIENCE AND I
WAS ONE OF THOSE WHO WAS
INSPIRED.
TO PURSUE PUBLIC.
PUBLIC OFFICE BECAUSE IDEA AYE
LOOKING AT HIM REALIZE THAT IT'S
POSSIBLE FOR SOMEONE LIKE ME TO
ALSO BE AN OFFICE.
HE INSPIRED A GENERATION OF
ARMENIANS INTO PUBLIC SERVICE
AND I THINK IN FOR HIS COURAGE.
HONESTY AND PASSION MY THOUGHTS
AND PRAYERS ARE WITH HIS WIFE
GLORIA CHILDREN AND LOVED ONES
THANK YOU.
THE COMMISSION IS AREA MISTER
ALLEN. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
IT LOOKS RISE IN HONOR. OF
GEORGE MAGE ALSO KNOWN AS THE
IRON DUKE.
THE THIRTY FIFTH GOVERNOR'S IN
CALIFORNIA.
GEORGE MAJOR IN ON A VERY CIVIL
PLATFORM PUBLIC SAFETY AND
BALANCED BUDGET. USE HIGHLY
CRITICAL OF JERRY BROWN IS FIRST
YOU TERMS OF OFFICE AND HE RAN
AGAINST THE FORMER MAYOR OF LOS
ANGELES TOM BRADLEY.
DEGRADED WAS NOT SUPPOSED TO WIN
ALL OF THE POLLS ACTUALLY HAD
HIM DOWN AND HAD HIM IS LOSING.
EVEN THE EXIT POLLS THE NIGHT OF
THE ELECTION SHOWED HIM LOSING.
BUT HE WAS VICTORIOUS IN WHEN HE
WON.
HE FOUGHT AGAINST TAX INCREASE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HE
WAS KNOWN AS THE LAW AND ORDER
CANDIDATE. HE WAS ACTUALLY THE
ONE ALSO THAT ENSURED THAT WE
HAVE THE DEATH PENALTY HEARING
CALIFORNIA.
HE WAS HIGHLY CRITICAL OF THE
COURTS ARE HIGHLY CRITICAL OF
JERRY BROWN'S APPOINTMENTS I TO
THE SUPREME COURT SPECIFICALLY
ROSE BIRD WHO WAS RELATOR
REMOVED FROM OFFICE BY THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
GEORGIA MEIJIN FOR A TIME WAS
THE ONLY REPUBLICAN STATEWIDE
OFFICEHOLDER IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND HE SHOWED WHAT REAL BALANCE
CAN BRING THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HE WAS A GREAT MAN.
IT TIMES YOU SAW SPOKEN.
BUT HE ALWAYS KNEW EXACTLY WHERE
IT CAME FROM HE KNEW EXACTLY
WHAT HE STOOD FOR AND THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA WERE MADE BETTER
OFF. LAYER THREE THROUGH
GOVERNOR STATE OF CALIFORNIA THE
IRON DUKE GEORGE MAJOR.
MR MACE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
I THINK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
AND MEMBERS I ALSO RISE TO SAY A
FEW WORDS IN MEMORY OF OUR
FORMER GOVERNOR GEORGE
DEUKMEJIAN.
ALTHOUGH I DIDN'T KNOW GOVERNOR
DUKMAJIAN PERSONALLY THERE'S A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT EACH OF US CAN
LEARN.
FROM HIS SERVICE HIS CHARACTER
AND GOVERNING STYLE REPRESENTED
THE GOOD.
IN AMERICAN POLITICS AND I THINK
WE COULD SEE THAT WITH THE
NUMBER OF DEMOCRATS THAT ROSE TO
JOIN IN HIS MEMORY.
TODAY.
HE WAS A PRINCIPAL CONSERVATIVE
THAT MUCH LIKE REAGAN BELIEVES.
I KNOW YOU KNEW. THERE WAS
ENOUGH ROOM IN THE TENT FOR
EVERYONE.
HE REPRESENTED US ALL WITH
POLICIES THAT PUT PEOPLE FIRST.
MANY RECALL GOVERNOR DEUKMEJIAN
IS DISCRETE DEMEANOR.
A STARK CONTRAST WITH TODAY'S
SHOUTING THAT OCCURS.
ON CABLE NEWS AND ON SOCIAL
MEDIA ON BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE.
IT WAS THROUGH HIS QUIET
LEADERSHIP THAT THE BIG FIVE WAS
CREATED IN FOR THE PATH FOR
MUTUAL RESPECT.
ACROSS PARTY LEADERSHIP.
HIS PASSING LEAVES A VOID IN
CALIFORNIA POLITICS ONE THAT I
HOPE WILL BE FILLED. IN THE
MONTHS AND YEARS AHEAD.
MY HOPE EXTENDS THE NEXT
GENERATION OF LEADERS THOSE OF
US HERE. IN THIS CHAMBER.
WHO WILL CONTINUE TO WALK DOWN
THE HONORABLE AND DIGNIFIED PATH
JUST LIKE?
GOVERNOR GEORGE DEUKMEJIAN.
IN REALITY WASN'T A CHOICE FOR
HIM.
IT WAS WHO HE WAS.
DIGNIFIED.
PRINCIPLED.
STRONG.
THANK YOU MEMBERS.
THANK YOU MISTER MAYES AND THANK
YOU MEMBERS.
MISTER DALLI FOR YOUR
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
DO YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I
RISE TODAY TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY
OF THE FORMER STATE SENATOR SAM
HONEST IT.
IN NINETEEN NINETY A. CENTER
HONEST THAT LEFT HIS SUCCESSFUL
PRACTICE AS AN ORAL SURGEON. IN
NEVADA COUNTY TO ANSWER THE CALL
A PUBLIC SERVICE.
REPRESENTING THE PEOPLE OF
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA ASSEMBLY AND
THE SENATE FOR TWELVE YEARS OF
HIS LIFE.
I WAS LUCKY ENOUGH TO INHERIT
SOME OF SENATOR ARMISTEAD STAFF
IN MY OFFICE.
MY DEPUTY CHIEF OF STAFF JERRY
WEST HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF
WORKING.
WITH HIM NOT ONLY IN THE CAPITAL
BUT ALSO IN HIS DENTAL PRACTICE
IN THE BALLOT COUNTING.
SENATOR ON INSTEAD WAS AN HONEST
AND SINCERE POLITICIAN WHO IS
TRULY DEDICATED TO SERVING HIS
COMMUNITY.
HE WILL BE MISSED BY HIS FAMILY
AND FRIENDS IN THE NORTH STATE
AS WELL AS THIS KID THIS CAPITAL
COMMUNITY MEMBERS PLEASE.
ADJOURNED IN MEMORY OF SENATOR
SAM HONEST IT.
THANK YOU WHICH DALY.
DOCTOR WOULD.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBER
I TWO WOULD LIKE TO RISE AND
HONOR THE MEMORY OF.
SENATOR SAM ON INSTEAD.
SAM.
.
WAS IT THE FIRST DENTIST IN THE
LEGISLATURE HE'S OBVIOUSLY NOT
THE LAST.
M. BUT HE WAS A HE WAS AN
HONEST MAN.
HE WAS A PASSIONATE MAN.
AND HE'S A PRINCIPLED MAN.
AND. HE DID SUFFER FOOLS LIGHTLY
ANYBODY. THERE ARE PEOPLE AROUND
HERE PRICE TO REMEMBER THAT.
HE WAS STILL ACTUALLY
PRACTICING DENTISTRY WHILE HE
WAS IN THE LEGISLATURE AND I
KEISLING COUNTERED HIM. AS I DO
TO RATE MAINTAIN MY LICENSE A
CONTINUING EDUCATION CLASSES.
HIS HIS DEPARTURE AND RUN FOR
THE LEGISLATURE WAS WHAT GAVE ME
AN OPPORTUNITY TO BE ACTIVE IN
MY ASSOCIATION AND ULTIMATELY
END UP HERE ALTHOUGH THAT WAS
NOT A PLAN AT THE TIME SO.
I JUST WANNA SAY THAT SO.
.
HE.
HE HE DID INSPIRE ME IN MANY
WAYS WE DIDN'T AGREE POLITICALLY
A LOT OF THINGS.
BUT I APPRECIATE PASSION.
AND HIS OF HIS ABILITY ABILITY
TO. IMPART THAT UPON PEOPLE.
HE WAS ALSO AN ANNOUNCER BY
THOSE ON THE LEFT THAT HE FOR
THE IN THE BATTLE CITY HIGH
SCHOOL FOOTBALL TEAM FOR MANY
YEARS THAT WAS ONE OF THE THINGS.
HE HAD TO GIVE UP WHEN HE CAME
HERE TO LEGISLATURE SO OUR
THOUGHTS GOT THE SUSAN HIS WIFE
HAS THREE GROWN CHILDREN AND HIS
GRANDCHILDREN I ASKED WE. OF THE
JOURNEY HIS MEMORY I WILL ADD
ONE THING HIS NAME WAS A LITTLE
YOU READ IT IT WAS A LITTLE
HARDER HARD TO. PRONOUNCE MAYBE
SO WHEN PEOPLE WERE CAMPAIGNING
FOR AND THEY ACTUALLY SAID JUST
REMEMBERED AS HIM AS. HONEST ADD
AND THAT'S HOW THAT'S HOW PEOPLE
CAN REMEMBER HIS NAME. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MEMBERS.
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS
TUESDAY MAY FIFTEENTH CHECKING
SESSION WEDNESDAY MAY SIXTEENTH
CHECK IN SESSION THURSDAY MAY
SEVENTEENTH.
FLOOR SESSION IS AT NINE AM ALL
OF THE ITEMS REMAINING WE PASS
RETAIN ALL MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUED.
SO YOU'RE HEARING OF FOR THE
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN. MISTER
STEINORTH MOVES AND MISTER
GRAYSON SECONDS.
THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED
UNTIL THURSDAY MAY SEVENTEENTH
AT NINE A. M. IN THE QUORUM CALL
IS LIFTED